foreign
[Music]
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__] this
is the Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [__] eating
[__] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
thank you
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy what a day
what a day what a day of news
so they're gonna be cellmates apparently
listen to all the moglades out there
really upset that Hunter Biden is
getting a plea deal your orange
Mussolini Jesus
can 100 percent
he can he can plea plead guilty that's
what he can do he could walk in to a
courthouse right now and say you know
what I want to change I want to change
how I pled at my arraignment I want to
plead guilty he can ask he can ask
Reinhardt he could ask Canon apparently
Canon is trying to Fast Track the the uh
trial don't get too excited though
everyone's getting excited this morning
that somehow Donald Trump's gonna go on
trial in August
I'll get too excited
this is this is par for the course
um when they set a trial like this
that this isn't going to happen I'll
give you an example
I'll give you a good example
um the Stuart Rhodes Oath Keepers trial
that's a good example the proud boys
there is a another good example
of how they set the trial reset the
trial reset the trial reset the trial
so don't get too excited
about having a trial in August because
it's it's just not going to happen
I hate to break it to you
and give you the truth
but apparently Hunter Biden has worked a
deal he listens to his lawyers
I I guess I guess Tom Fenton isn't part
of Hunter Biden's
legal defense
if Tom Fenton was part of Hunter Biden's
legal defense Hunter Biden would have
been doing like a thousand interviews
totally admitting to his crimes right
out in the open probably going on Fox
News
and admitting to his crimes last night
oh wait that wasn't that wasn't Hunter
Biden that was that was the Cheeto dust
q and honor oh it's Grandpa boopy Pants
last night on Fox News
giving an interview oh my God let me let
me tell you something folks
any other time in modern history if
there would have been a former president
go on
a a cable TV station
and be interviewed
by somewhat a serious interviewer right
Brett Baer did a much better job than
Sean Hannity could ever dream of [__]
doing
because Sean Hannity genuflex to this
idiot
Brett bailed last night
didn't exactly do
the entirety of what he should have done
buddy got pretty goddamn close
I mean Grandpa got really upset at him
when Brett Bear had to tell him look man
you [__] lost the election in 2020. I
mean he got pissed
it's quite the sight to see but here's
the thing in our modern politics there
would never ever be a former president
who was trying to rerun after he lost
that would survive that interview
nope not gonna happen
folks if he survives this interview
which he's going to they're not I don't
know if you noticed this on online today
whether you're on Facebook or you're on
Twitter
I don't know if you noticed this they're
not walking from this fool like last
night that I mean Benny Johnson Benji is
on Twitter like yeah Trump trump really
showed Brett Bear
what are are we on the same planet
are we on the same planet
now Benny Johnson is a [__]
chucklehead and he's gonna lie and he's
gonna Gaslight his viewers and he's
gonna feed the lines that his viewers
need to explain away the [__] show that
was on Fox news last night where Donald
Trump admitted to its crimes
it's it's wild [__] it's wild [__] man
this this is a hell of a time to be
alive it really is and we are truly at
the intersection of WrestleMania in real
life I've been saying this for a long
time
no one no one really believes me
sometimes I think I don't think I think
a lot of people are like yeah yeah maybe
Maybe
I'm telling you this is professional
[__] wrestling go watch go watch any
clips
a professional wrestling right when the
heel comes out
go watch it
and the [__] Crowd Goes Wild
when the heel comes out they're like
yeah [__] yeah there's about to be some
crazy chaos about to happen in the ring
that's what's happening
they're [__] excited that this guy is
gonna cause chaos
and and during the wrestling matches if
you go watch a clip of a good you know
good old wrestling match from the 1990s
early 2000s like that's the you know
what I'm talking about
it's like the prime before before they
all merged and became one
and then they could just do whatever
they wanted they didn't have to compete
with anyone
it's it's [__] crazy though
it's the same reaction that you get
I mean Benny Johnson is tweeting out
like yeah Trump really showed Brett Bear
Brett Bear was speechless
yeah Brett Bear was speechless because
Brett Bear didn't understand that this
guy was gonna [__] admit to his
felonies on the [__] camera machine
thing what are you he's yep he just said
yeah he definitely just said he had
Iranian nuclear secrets
wild [__] man
and then he came up with a whole new
excuse last night right whole new excuse
now he's been he's been working on this
one he's and to be fair he's been
working this material okay
and a lot of this material has been
worked in these Twitter spaces that we
go into I don't know if you know this we
go into Twitter spaces uh Mario's room
and there's a lot of [__] [__]
in there a lot of [__] [__] eaters
Benny Johnson is one of them Tom Fenton
Sebastian Gorka
a lot of these [__] come in
this room uh DC Drano you know Rogaine
you know him a lot of these
[__] come in this room and
they're trying out material they're
trying out their narrative right that's
what they're doing in these Twitter
spaces and really that what they're
doing is they're they're [__] out
stuff into the universe to see what
feedback comes back what's the what what
argument do people catch on the most
that's what they're doing
they're trying it out now again I I'm
not opposed to this I think the left
could learn a lot from this
the left could learn a shitload from
this
about this WrestleMania real life thing
I'm dead serious I I know you're like
Tony Jesus Christ dude we want to act
like them look do you want to [__]
win or do you want to [__] lose
huh what what which is it
do you want to elect serious
[__] to run our government or
do you want to just just
lay down your [__] and let these [__]
idiots do it
huh what what would you decide
and you think you think playing nice is
gonna beat these people you're [__]
out of your mind
you're out of your mind if you think
playing nice and playing by oh we have
to we have to look like we're playing by
the rules we can't we can't get out of
bounds bull [__] [__] we can't
if you if you watched last night that
lunatic give that interview
and you're like you know what
I'm not willing to go to any extent to
make sure that he's not president you're
you're [__] more of a lunatic than he
is
that's that's it
you're more of a lunatic than they are
than he is if you're just gonna not if
you're gonna say well [__] that I'm not
I'm not gonna go to that extent
for our democracy
I can't do that [__]
I'm going to you goddamn right I'm going
to that's why I go in those Twitter
spaces that's why I listen to them
that's why I go in and throw a few
Fireballs at them
get them good and pissed off at me I'm
gonna give a [__]
because that's where their narrative is
folks that's listen do you know how I
stay ahead of it
it's not a big secret
I'm not all-knowing I don't have a
crystal ball it may seem like it
sometimes
but the reason why is because I know
what they're doing
I've watched it
I've watched it for decades how they do
this
that's why I've been trying to convey to
you that this show that right here is
how we do it
yes is it if we catch on here
at this show which our gay our audience
is gaining steam but if we really catch
on I mean big time
everyone's gonna copy us
on the left they're gonna copy this show
you're gonna see a ton of them spring up
and they're and and people are going to
say oh he's he's trying to do the Tony
Michaels thing
that's fine that's great that's what we
need that's what the [__] we need
we need loud voices we need crazy we
need our circus
how do you think we're going to win
don't worry about the candidates listen
the reason why it seems so weird
and it seems so out of place of what the
Republican party has done is because
they have taken the circus and the clown
show and they have put the clowns in
charge
of the government that's why you're like
what the [__] is this [__] this is weird
now I'm not proposing that we put the
clowns in charge of the government I
should not be anywhere near government
okay
I should not be anywhere near policy
I'm a commentator
I'm a narrative Setter that is what I do
that's my role in politics
that's what I I'm the circus clown I'm
the clown that distracts the bull right
hey over here [__]
so they don't [__] kill people
but we have we have to get on that page
we must
folks they're not gonna leave him I
don't know if you noticed this this
morning but their support is his support
from the cult is not waning
and the only thing that he did last
night was make sure to suppress the
Republican vote
mark my words do you know how many
commercials you don't have any ads we
can cut during the general election from
that [__] [__] show last night that
will suppress the vote
their vote that's right we talked about
it yesterday with Fred Wellman
if you don't believe that one of our
major strategies the best strategy we
have is to get people who would vote
Republican no matter what to stay the
[__] at home
that's one of our strategies yes you
goddamn right
you God damn right
it's one of our strategies
folks we don't have a lot of time here
we don't now all the tools are laid out
right in front of us right there's
there's millions of rakes to throw on
the ground for these idiots to step on I
mean this morning
Kevin McCarthy is already bitching again
about the two-tier justice system and
what's crazy about it I've been saying
this for [__] months as they've been
bitching about the two-tier justice
system they tried this out in the
Twitter space they tried it out there
that's the first place I heard it and I
start telling you hey they're not mad
that there's a two-tier justice system
they're not mad about it they're mad
that the second tier that privileged
tear
that is supposed to
protect Trump is no longer protecting
him that's why they're mad
they're not mad because there's a
two-tier justice system
their man it's not protecting their
orange deity anymore to the extent that
they wanted to because technically it is
this morning Kevin McCarthy's like oh
there's there's two tiered yes this
minion skantry and Hunter Biden just he
pled guilty to a felony and two
misdemeanors uh from a trump appointing
United States Attorney and um he's gonna
he's gonna not serve a day in jail
probably probation and there's two deer
Justice and that's what we want for
Trump we want him to get that privileged
tear like he's saying it out loud
yeah no [__] yeah we we can see it
you don't think you don't think that
narrative could [__] we could run
with that and piss America off at
Republicans absolutely we could
their argument is Trump doesn't get the
second privileged tier anymore he used
to but he's not now Hunter Biden is
we're mad about it so why we should be
mad that Trump isn't getting this
privileged tear trust me there's a
privilege here trust me trust me on this
I know personally I know personally
there's a second privileged here in this
country because if my skin color was
different I'd still be in prison
that's the [__] truth
that's the truth
but it isn't so there is a second tier
for people who have money who can afford
lawyers as long as they listen to them
that's the other thing at play here is
Hunter Biden listened to his [__]
attorneys
he didn't go on podcast episodes and
admit to his [__] crimes he kept his
mouth shut
and by the way I just want to point this
out too to all moglodytes out there
Hunter Biden will never ever ever be the
Democratic party's nominee for president
of the United States it's just not going
to happen we don't give a [__] about him
we don't want him to be president we
don't want him to have the nuclear
secrets we do not want him to have the
codes got it
we don't want him stealing documents
from the government possibly to make
crack deals and buy prostitutes and
hookers we just don't want it so that's
why we we in the Democratic party
wouldn't put him in charge of [__]
do you see how that works
do you see the [__] difference morons
you are you are clamoring
to have your criminal be in charge of
everything really you want them to be
authoritarian dictator
and again I'm not I'm not disparaging
Coke and hookers I mean there's nothing
wrong with it I actually think it
shouldn't be [__] illegal and the and
the felony charge holy [__] the felony
charge that's wild wild [__] felony
charge
that you can't possess a firearm why why
you're an addict for drugs come on
doesn't that infringe the Second
Amendment a little bit don't you think
don't you think that's an infringement
huh huh
you two abros out there should be super
[__] pissed that they can charge him
with that even you dumb [__]
yet you're not
you're not because you're too [__]
clouded your mind has melted
you have a [__] disease it's the woke
mind virus is what she got friend
maybe you should have got the 5G vaccine
and your ass wouldn't be in such bad
shape
maybe you should do a little blow and
get some hookers maybe that'd wake you
up a little bit
to the [__] truth
and the truth is is that yes there is a
two-tier justice system in this country
and Donald Trump pushed it to the very
[__] Brink to where the government
had no [__] choice but to charge him
with 37 felonies on the Espionage Act
they had no [__] Choice he made them
make that choice
and Hunter Biden decided to listen to
his [__] attorneys not ignore them
and not try to get them to commit crime
with him by obstructing
so he did he made a [__] deal he got
a [__] deal and it's a [__] Rosy
deal with that to be quite honest
if what you say is true about Hunter
Biden moglodytes oh it's a sweet deal
oh man who wouldn't trade that 10
million dollar bribery payment for a
couple couple misdemeanors on your taxes
in a gun charge huh who wouldn't do that
and just play into their delusion folks
they're not going to believe they're not
going to believe the truth
they're not they never will even even
long after Grandpa's gone and he's
choked and died on a cheeseburger
probably a Big Mac
I don't know maybe a Double Quarter
Pounder is it easier to choke on a Big
Mac or a Double Quarter Pounder I don't
know I'm not sure I don't know the
science behind that maybe we should
investigate that make sure he's eating
one or the other more often just saying
I'm just throwing that out there you
know
these aren't conspiracy theories these
are wishes
but long after he's gone folks long
after that [__] has croaked and
they have thrown the last shovel of dirt
on his [__] grave
they are still going to yell and scream
about the two-tier justice system and
how Donald Trump was treated unfairly
because he was not afforded his
privilege
he was not afforded he was afforded his
privilege you stupid [__] he was
afforded the same privileges Hunter
Biden
he was given plenty of time to negotiate
he wouldn't negotiate he wouldn't listen
to his attorneys
and therefore he's charged with 37
felonies in South Florida
in a federal court
and he's likely he's likely
going to to serve some sentence for
those felonies
now I don't know what that looks like I
don't I you know they set the trial for
August 14th but that ain't gonna happen
that ain't gonna happen
don't get too [__] excited I'm
telling you
again just some prime examples
of setting a trial to get the process
moving forward just look at The Oath
Keepers trial
and the proud boys trial just look at
those and do the timeline from when the
crime happened do it the timeline from
when the crime happened to when the
trial started just do the timeline
and and it's a very easy it's a very
easy thing to look at and go yeah he's
not he's not going to see a trial
anytime soon
but boy is it going to be fun in the
meantime
we got Texas poets [__] Tuesday you
know we got Texas Paul here how the hell
couldn't Texas Paul come and talk about
Grandpa poopypants's interview last
night and then the news of Hunter Biden
getting charged with two misdemeanors
are taking a plea deal for two
misdemeanors and a felony gun charge I
gotta ask Texas Paul he was tweeting
about this gun charge earlier this is a
weird [__] gun charge it's [__]
wild I can't believe that most of the
two a Bros out there aren't really
[__] pissed off about this charge I I
can't even believe that they don't even
know that it doesn't exist this is an
infringement as far as I'm concerned if
you're looking at it through the
Periscope of two abros this is
infringement on the Second Amendment and
it shall not stand Hunter Biden should
not have to plead guilty to this charge
as far as you know a two-way bro should
be concerned I believe but you know this
is how it goes they needed a felony I
believe so we're gonna ask Texas Paul
about that felony I hope he's hope he's
looked into it a little bit I know I
know he said he was he was looking into
it so we'll ask him about that we're
also I'm going to show you the Kevin
McCarthy clip oh my God this guy this
guy just he is so [__] dumb no wonder
they didn't want him to be speaker I
thought it was because he wasn't manga
enough but he's just dumb as dog [__] he
is so [__] stupid he didn't even have
a prepared statement for the hunter
Biden [__] when the reporters asked him
this morning it's obvious it's obvious
he had no prepared statement and really
they're boxed in here especially by this
interview last night with Brett Bear and
boy are we going to show you clips from
that because it is wild [__] I cannot
believe he agreed to do that I can't
believe some of the [__] he said and
really honestly I I tweeted last night
hand get this guy a bigger [__]
shovel please will you get him a bigger
shovel this is great if he's gonna dig
his grave let's get him a backhoe and
let's do that
oh we got all that all the news coming
at you so don't don't miss a single
minute make sure you subscribe to the
Tony Michaels podcast right here on
YouTube subscribe subscribe subscribe we
are past 16 000. you know what someone
was saying the other day I I posted that
we got the 16 000 I thanked all of you
and I really thank all of you because
that's the biggest help that you can
give is go follow us not just on YouTube
but everywhere follow us on Twitter uh
go to Facebook you can watch us on
Facebook but if you got a Facebook
account follow us on Facebook at the
Tony Michaels you can follow us on
Twitch it's it's free to follow us on
Twitch twitch.tv see Tony Michaels it's
free to download this show every single
weekday
those free things those things that are
free are the biggest help you can give
us and I appreciate every single one of
you here every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific for two full hours because we
don't let up here
I barely take a breath for two hours why
do you think my face is so goddamn red
everyone always oh man Tony's getting
pissed off his face is red that's
because I I don't want there to be a gap
you know what I mean mind the gap
oh boy you're the best audience in the
world I'm glad to have you I want to get
down and see what Texas Paul has to say
about the news so don't go anywhere
while you're waiting on the commercial
make sure that the [__] subscribe
button it doesn't cost anything share it
with a couple friends while you're
waiting for us to come back from
commercial don't go anywhere we'll be
right back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
speak in a pardon figure had a brilliant
idea I just had a brilliant idea
um you know how they want they want the
any candidate
Donald Trump you know what I want Joe
Biden I want Joe Biden to pledge that he
will that he will pardon Hunter Biden
his son from these felonies I think that
hey why not why not you know what the
president has unilateral power that's
what the mongolo knights will tell you
all they have to do is thinking in their
mind just a president of the United
States just has thinking in their mind
bam it happens that's how it happens
Texas Paul you know this welcome to the
show my friend boy what a day huh
couldn't happen I was always glad to be
here Tony I am always glad to be here
it's always a good day when I get to see
it I look forward to Tuesdays yeah all
the time but today today's special
Tuesday it is hell of a Tuesday isn't it
I woke up this morning I'm like oh my
God what a big news day what a big news
day
um so let's talk about this because I
know you were questioning this gun
charge on your Twitter account earlier
of Hunter Biden we find out that this
gun charge is a felony a low-lying
felony in in the world of gun charges
and it's kind of odd um it's very rare
and it seems like they use this
um for like drug dealers more than
anything
um because they want to get them on a
gun charge uh to give them more years in
prison that's typically what happens but
this gun charge is possession of a
firearm while being an addict basically
you're addicted to drugs and you got a
gun you know I I find it hilarious that
2A Bros run around talking about you
can't even friends I might ride some
blah blah blah and they don't even know
that there's Federal felonies out there
that half of them would be charged with
like they have no idea and they would
never be able to possess a firearm again
do you think they're aware of that do
they think I mean they're not aware of
much but
no I I quite honest with you I I think a
lot of right-wingers are going to
actually wake up this morning read the
news and realize that um yeah they've
been
committing this felony for a very very
long time right well I mean just to give
you an example Donald Trump Jr
um obviously has an addiction problem it
seems at least I mean just by his his
body language his the color of his nose
it really does seem like you have a drug
addiction and he possesses firearms
because he makes videos shooting them so
um couldn't they charge Donald Trump Jr
with this I mean realistically I mean
why not why not I mean why not why not
we should do that I mean there shouldn't
be a two-tier Jazz assistant Texas ball
everyone who has this felony should be
held accountable to this film I think
there shouldn't be a two-tier justice
system that's what Maga that's what
manga is fighting this morning
you know like I said this morning you
know it is what it is I mean being the
son of a president ha it's a
double-sided sword it really is
especially if you're a Democrat because
there are different rules for
republicans and Democrats what Hunter
Biden's going through is exactly what he
deserves he is I'll just say that right
now he did what he did he got he's being
prosecuted is it an unfair prosecution
are they going a little hard on him I
believe so I believe so because the tax
charges would have been handled civilly
they would have been civil charges but
the gun charge itself no he earned that
some [__] he really did wow this law
was put in place yeah well I I I want to
go one step further because I think they
were they needed the prosecutor needed a
felony right and they didn't want felony
tax charges the hunter Biden's defense
team because they knew it was more
likely he would serve prison time if he
had felony tax charges and this this
low-lying weird felony for the firearm
what it does is two two things number
one it gets the felon money on on Hunter
Biden's record and it makes it to where
he's not going to be able to possess
Firearms ever again and that's probably
good for Hunter Biden to be quite honest
the guy probably shouldn't be around you
he obviously does not make great
decisions uh when he's on drugs and the
guy likes drugs
um not that there's anything wrong with
that I think if you want to do drugs hey
whatever but Firearms should not be
involved in those equations so and
here's the thing that Hunter Biden might
still see a prison sentence I doubt it I
think he's going to get probation for
these charges what do you think
oh absolutely I do I think that was a
deal see people are already coming at me
about well what about Alan weisselberg
he went to jail and I'm like different
crimes right different actions by the
defendant Biden has for example one
example is weisselberg still hasn't even
paid the taxes that he was supposed to
have paid he's still paying those off
the hunter Biden when they said okay you
didn't pay taxes here he said okay give
me my checkbook and he wrote a check and
said okay here you go I paid my taxes
and he cooperated fully with the
investigation it's always the cover-up
that ends up getting these right Wingers
right-wingers because they think they're
smarter than everybody the gun charge
though what we were talking about with
the gun charge that has been around
since the really been since the War on
Drugs came about remember there was that
whole raft of laws that they passed and
and they really started using Rico and
and whatnot this gun charge that he is
facing is the same gun charge you get
with uh um you know like drug dealers
and stuff all the time well right I met
I've met guys who who got this gun
charge I've met people who have got this
gun charge and um almost every single
one of them their skin is brown or black
then that's that's that's the truth of
the matter this law was written um to
make sure that black men went to prison
um that was simply put and and that they
went to prison for multiple felonies
um that's what this is and and the
reason why is because when they would
raid someone's house they could say oh
yeah you got drugs and you got a gun so
now not only do you have a felony drug
charge you got a felony gun charge even
though it doesn't really have anything
to do with each other like there's no
there's no Amendment about drugs but
there's a moment about the second
there's Amendment about Firearms which
it should be unimpringible which again
it just it seems weird that two abros
aren't really mad this morning about
the discharge and the reason why they're
not mad about this charge is because
they're delusional they just they're so
cloudy with all the lies and [__] that
they can't see the light of day
I think I I might have lost your audio
I'm not sure
yeah you're muted now yeah I had to mute
it because for some reason my Bluetooth
is going crazy
um
and I I missed a half of what you what
you said because I lost my audio I
apologize for that but what we're you
know what we're talking about with it
there's actually a case going forward
right now uh I believe the guy's name is
Carrizo
um again a a guy that is that is a
Hispanic he is going to end up paying
I was going crazy let me just pull these
out
um it's going to end up paying
criminally for this BS nonsense
of a law that really it was put in place
to to get to Target uh drug dealers and
and and throw like you said throw an
extra charge on top to add to that jail
time now you know I understand
the idea behind it you're trying to
Target to to reduce the amount of gun
violence and stuff involved with the
drug trade Etc but that doesn't really
apply here
I mean he wasn't out slinging drugs
that's not what he was doing he was just
an addict he was an addict well and I I
actually I actually believe that the
defense
um again Hunter Biden probably uh did
the right thing by not saying a lot of
[__] in public by not having a lot of
people do a lot of interviews with him
uh in public and I I believe I believe
that he did the right thing here
listening to his defense and his defense
was able to work these charges right
that he pled guilty to and that's and
that's the thing I want to go to the uh
Kevin McCarthy
um clip here here's here's Kevin
McCarthy when he's asked about the
hunter Biden charges this morning what's
listening
my first reaction is it continues to
show
the two-tier system in America if you
were the president's leading political
opponent doj tries to literally put you
in jail give you present time you are
the president's son you get a sweetheart
game now this does nothing to our
investigation it actually should enhance
our investigations because the doj
should not be able to withhold any
information now
so there he is basically admitting what
we all know that yes there is a two-tier
justice system and Hunter Hunter Biden
and and Donald Trump have been protected
by this two-tier justice system for a
long time
well yeah and you know man I I want to
say this I mean while I think that this
law is really you abused by prosecutors
and in this case really shouldn't apply
uh so much but it's neither here nor
there it was the [__] law Tony
and he broke it
and he should be prosecuted for it and
if we don't like it change the law but
you know I just can't I can't defend
Hunter Biden here in this situation I I
can't I mean it's just part of that
double-edged sword if you're a
Republican and the son of a president
you get special treatment Don Jr
everybody knows that dude has enough
Coke on him to drop a freaking rhino
and nobody touches that are you talking
about like a rhino the animal or Rhino
like a republican to name him no I mean
the animal I mean he could I mean
that dude is so freaking high so often
law enforcement knows it but they're not
going to touch that guy they're not
Trump how many times has he paid
you know been caught cheating on his
taxes have you know and all he did was
pay fines
no you're a Democrat so we're going to
go after that criminally
in no small part because the prosecutor
here was a trump appointee and is a
maggot
that that's who's who they are I mean
but again reality folks that's our
reality that's our political reality
that's what we live with Hunter Biden
knew it he you know and he did what he
did he was a pardon the expression
despite the fact that professionally he
has been incredibly successful that he's
well educated and all the other things
the guy's an addict and a [__] up when
it comes to drugs he is he just is he's
an addict and a [__] up when it comes to
drugs
he said it himself it goes back to
watching his mother and his sister die
in the front seat of the car he was in
and he's never gotten over that right
and let me ask you a Texas ball let me
ask you and I want to ask the audience
this to you how many of you plan on
voting for Hunter Biden
how many of you plan on hey do you plan
on hunting or voting for Hunter Biden
you plan on voting
doesn't apply does it
what do you mean I mean he's obviously
the president isn't he to some degree I
mean he's he's the president right I
mean we're going to be able to vote for
Hunter Biden aren't we
no yeah this yeah I mean the guy is
nobody's a private citizen this is not
going to carry over on a Joe Biden like
they hope it will I mean you have to
remember this prosecution started in the
middle of the Trump presidency he is
claiming you know to be a victim and the
weaponization of government and and
whatnot this prosecution started
when Trump was President I mean this was
this was his appointed prosecutor they
went after Hunter Biden
you know Hunter Biden just hired an
attorney and cooperated too much to
their Chagrin what are you going to do
right you know I mean the guy the guy
opened up his books they went through
his books he paid his fines uh paid back
his back taxes he did what he was
supposed to do he's not running for
office this isn't going to stick that's
not that's not what you would read over
in manga Universe today today it's
almost like we're voting for Hunter
Biden right and we got 100 Biden flags
on the back of our trucks we got 100
buying bumper stickers on our cars
um we wear Hunter Biden hats
um uh make cocaine great again is what
we wear those hats that we've got you
know what I mean we've got all this we
got all this great stuff we got all this
great stuff that we that we are the cult
of Hunter Biden it seems like we should
be voting for Hunter Biden I don't know
I'm just saying I'm just saying I mean I
mean look at look at Don well hang on
hang on there there's someone there's
someone here here's here's Gabe Sanchez
here's Gabe Sanchez Gabe uh Texas Paul
is having a little audio issues this
morning
um so do you want you want to come back
Paul once you get it figured out I'm
here man I'm here I'm oh okay okay you
got you got it whipped is your Bluetooth
on now I think so you know you know
yesterday
it must be something it must be the Deep
state or some [__] because yesterday
Gabe Sanchez was having uh problems with
his internet and then today it's your
audio so I think this is like a deep
State thing uh probably because we're
talking about Hunter bikes I've never
had this problem well it's probably that
we're talking about Hunter Biden and I
know Hunter Biden controls the
government he controls the government so
that's I want to show you this I want to
show you a um I want to show you a great
uh statement by a guy named Donald Trump
now it's Donald Trump Jr
um but in this statement this is
literally what he tweeted the blatantly
politicized nature of Joe Biden's
justice department under A.G Garland
couldn't be more clear today oh really
let's let's hear it let's see what you
have to say the plea deal that they cut
with Hunter reeks a favoritism
favoritism from what the United States
Attorney that your dad appointed hmm
seems kind of weird uh and recently
reveals a system where there are two
tiers of Justice yeah no [__] Sherlock
you've taken advantage of it your whole
[__] life holy dependent on your
political affiliation you don't say you
don't say that Republican prosecutors
don't prosecute Republicans sometimes
because they don't want to to look bad
and it's funny that you point that out
Don Jr he said if you are Republican
Biden's doj will throw the book at you
and try to put you in prison for a
hundred years I mean the other day uh
technically grandpa said 400 years so I
think he's a little off here I mean I'm
all for a hundred but 400 sounds a lot
better to me I'm just saying Don Junior
if you're gonna go for the gold for a
real good lie go for 400 not 100 but you
know that's just me he goes on to say
but if you happen to have the right last
name like Hunter uh you got to be
[__] me come on man they will
protect you and treat you with kid
gloves really your last name is Trump
you [__] fool
who are they selling this [__] to he
says we are no longer a nation with
equal justice under law but rather
something more akin to a third world
Banana Republic where the law exists to
protect the ruling class he wants it to
protect the ruined glass and they want
to be the ruined class for sure while
targeting the opposition and then he
signs it Donald Trump Jr now this is all
just a this is all parrot from his
father from his father he wants to
appear Gabe Sanchez as his as if did he
is this like a notes like an iPhone like
which mic are you on pull your mic over
oh there we go yeah is it like uh sorry
man yeah the new setup I got laid out in
the desk I'll tell you I've actually got
an audio problem this morning too I I
have a different mic it looks like I'm
talking into this one but I'm not I'm
talking into a different one because
this one didn't start working when I the
show came looks like we've all got
technical difficulties don't we I just I
just uh fake it until I make it that's
the thing I think it is the Deep State
uh is that a
was that like an iOS notes thing that he
like make a note then took a screenshot
and then posted it I I think so because
here here's the here's the Tweet
um and yo this is like one of those
moments when somebody's like I just
wanna you know it's like their apology
letter that's how people do it they'll
they'll take a screenshot of a note that
they have from the front yeah this is a
[__] note thing right you know what
here's what I said I said you seem
triggered
because that's the name of his show yeah
why did he name his show that Texas
fault triggered and I I put quotes I put
bunny ears around I really should have
done more of them to be quite honest
like I should yeah he should have I mean
you should but he should have right I
mean you only had so many words you
could do I mean you could do I guess air
quotes around every word or letter right
you seem triggered yeah
[Music]
here's the thing like they're they're
going you know he's he's attacking last
name Hunter you know and was he
commenting on uh FBI director Ray is
that what he was doing no no AG Garland
as if A.G Garland had anything to do
with this deal oh yeah yeah yeah the
United States Attorney that made this
deal and then the attorney the attorney
the United States Attorney has been
investigating 100 Biden since Joe Biden
became uh president United States you
know what you know July 2018.
right right but when Joe Biden became
when Joe Joe Biden became president he
they were investigating his son right
and and you're right yeah instead of
politicizing the issue and getting rid
of that United States Attorney in
Delaware and appointing someone who may
have been more favorable to Hunter Biden
Joe Biden said you know what I'm going
to stay out of this I'm going to let
that United States Attorney stay as the
United States don't even know I don't
want him to I don't have a choice here
because he's investigating my son and I
don't want to appear biased so I'm just
going to let him keep investigating him
and I would imagine that once this case
is closed once they do this deal on
Hunter Biden this sentence I would
imagine that Joe Biden is going to
replace that U.S attorney that's that's
what he should do now it's Joe Biden's
presidency he should have the right to
go ahead and replace this attorney once
this case is closed that's what he
should do
um but it just it's hilarious it's
[__] hilarious that they're yelling
and screaming about that oh this U.S
attorney who's appointed by Trump
investigating Biden 100 Biden since
2018. Joe Biden didn't remove him let
him investigate him now now well the
reason I mean the the big reason why he
didn't do that was because he wanted to
remove any sort of ability for people to
say this was a political attack and they
were protecting him so he's like all
right fine we'll keep the guy that was
under Trump and we won't change a thing
because we don't want you to do anything
the same reason why they went you know
above and beyond when it comes to
Merrick Garland appointing Jack Smith
and Jack Smith doing everything to the
letter so that no one later on could be
like well this is this was a political
weaponization it's like no he followed
the exact rule in the exact process of
how you handle such an investigation
and unfortunately Republicans don't like
to accept the reality or the truth of
the matter they don't like the fact that
there's an investigation into both of
these people his father or you know
their father the cult leader Trump and
Hunter Biden and they don't like the
fact that also Donald Trump even this
week admitted to the fact that he wasn't
going to give the stuff up or he was
like oh I just have this random stuff oh
man we're gonna watch those kids it's
it's great it's fantastic
um here is here's Grandpa Poopypants
this morning about this decision
um of Hunter Biden his attorneys to do
their work that that Hunter Biden um
paid them to do which was to make a deal
with the prosecutors so that he would
serve the least amount of time possible
I don't know if Donald Trump realizes
this when you hire attorneys after
you've committed crime and you know
you've committed crime and you're
defending yourself against charges of
crime normally what you want the
attorneys to do is do their best work
stay out of their [__] way don't say
anything keep your [__] mouth shut
stay out of the way and let them work
the best [__] possible deal that you
can get so you can serve the least
amount of time because
98 of federal cases are plea deals
they're pleased and the reason why is
because the government's got all the
money and all the time they don't give a
[__] and also and also like if you're
smart I mean like look as easy on the
smart thing all right see I'm the smart
thing legal advice legal advice from
someone who is not a lawyer okay
it feels like it feels like there's a
small shirt that you're talking about
do not talk if you get arrested you get
pulled over you get detained shut up
you're shut you keep your [__] mouth
shut do not speak until you have some
sort of representation to actually speak
on your behalf but do not say a goddamn
word do not say anything it will be used
against you it's literally in your
Miranda Rights shut the [__] up wow he
has the right to remain silent he did
sure yeah you have the right to remain
silent but for anyone anyone for anyone
who is in that situation any people
watching or listening don't talk do not
talk wait for someone to talk on your
behalf especially if you did commit
crimes and they are gonna I want an
attorney I'm I'm asking for an attorney
I'd like to call my attorney
well and I I like I've told my son he's
going to be an adult too and I'm like
look if you ever get to where you're in
a situation where you're in a room and
they've arrested you with cops the only
word you say is attorney attorney
attorney attorney attorney attorney
that's the only that's the only language
in word you speak right right don't even
tell them your [__] name just say
attorney attorney attorney that's all
you got to say and eventually
um you know you'll have one there but
here's here's Grandpa's statement uh
this morning Texas Paul he says wow he's
really he's excited about this I guess
the corrupt Biden doj just cleared up
hundreds of years of criminal liability
by giving under Biden
a mere quote traffic ticket our system
is broken he got a felony there's a gun
charge felony in this Texas well now I
know it's not it's a rare felony but
Texas well he's a felon now right am I
wrong about this
uh yeah he pled guilty to it the thing
is that I think what they're working out
is a deal for a deferred adjudication on
that on that one
um if he goes through they'll they'll
make him go through another program
though and he'll have to not break any
laws for probably two years uh and this
will drop off his record and he won't be
a felon at that point so they're going
to suspend a judication or defer
adjudication on that matter so no
technically he won't be a felon
do you think that's why his defense
um got him this deal is because of that
so that they could adjudicate this
charge I you know I
well I I just think he has good lawyers
to be honest well I mean I mean again
there is a two-tier justice system in
which people are afforded better lawyers
than people who can't afford them that
is for sure true
and and David Weiss had to look at it
that way that the the the U.S attorney
that was Prosecuting this had to look at
it this way uh Hunter Biden is
financially successful the guy does make
money he makes more cash coming into his
his household than Donald Trump does for
his household I mean they shall say
Valentine's a billionaire are you but
Senator Biden's richer than Donald Trump
is that what you're saying
no I'm not saying he has a greater net
worth that's not what I'm saying I'm
saying his income is great Oh you mean
Donald Trump loses money he owns assets
that make him look Wealthy on the books
but those assets lose money
um Hunter Biden makes money and he had
the ability to financial wherewithal to
fight this out he really did
um politically nah David Weiss kind of
had him against the wall because this is
actually hurting his dad you know
putting into this before the next
lecture cycle which is what Donald Trump
was really pissed about I mean Donald
Trump knew he was going to get special
you know I won't say special treatment
he actually got worse treatment because
like I said those tax those
what he pled to on those tax laws he
could have easily fought those down to
being a civil prosecution that's it
we're not going to go after this
criminally he's already paid his
liabilities
he could have thought that that so yeah
it's kind of a mixed bag there yeah he
did do great on the on the gun felony
would defer to adjudication but he
royally got screwed on the on the tax
end of it because this didn't have to be
criminal at all and that will affect him
in the future going going forward
anyways I I know I'm not probably not
answering your question but
you know I want to say one thing you
were saying earlier about just deal with
it this is reality if you want to win do
what you have to do to win right this is
the kind of thing that I want to tell
people this is a perfect example of that
Hunter Biden is facing charges
he's pleading out to them charges that a
republican child would not face
the doj and IRS has considered
the Trump kids off limits I call them
kids they're all freaking adults the
Trump Offspring off limits they know
junior is a freaking addict they know
Jared Kushner there is plenty to look at
there like two billion things to look at
maybe I'm just saying yeah and they
don't look at they don't do it because
you don't go after the kids of former
presidents you don't have to go after
the kids or prisons Donald Trump broke
that precedent in 2018 when he sent this
U.S attorney he appointed this U.S
attorney and sent him directly after
Hunter Biden because the Republicans
believed that Hunter Biden was going to
be their ticket to the promised land
wait you're saying this is all political
is that what you're saying it's all
political it is all political
come on man you sound like a manga it is
political it's always political it's all
politics it always has been it will be
that the fact of what you're saying that
the Trump kids aren't elected are excuse
me aren't
prosecuted because their father is a
former elected president that's
political that's political there's
political [__] calculations in not
Prosecuting someone there's political
calculations when they do prosecute
someone who boneheads it is political
it's always political has to be right or
am I wrong
it well yeah it's political going one
way or the other it always is I mean it
really is it always is one way or the
other uh either political for you or
politically against you but you know
folks
Republicans get a pass I'm just gonna
say it they get a pass so freaking often
they'll get accused of crimes or there
will be outright crimes we know are
there you know you've got
Marjorie Trader green and her her
coveted money nobody's looking at that
nobody's gonna look at that you've got
tons of insider trading in Congress
um you you I don't know if we're going
to talk about it today but but Rand Paul
finally did the the financial releases
on his wife
when kovitz before you and I knew [__]
about covet and Rand Paul did had
already gotten the briefings his wife
went out and bought a ton
a ton of stock and Gilead yeah I wonder
how that happened here's another example
that Gabe sent me here Ben Shapiro says
uh why look a plea deal that involves no
jail time and uh Roger here points out
Roger Stone and his wife settled a 2
million unpaid tax civil case with the
doj last year they weren't charged
criminally unlike Hunter Biden so they
didn't even get probation this is Roger
Stone someone who has been in federal
court before I believe I think so I
think and he was uh what wasn't there a
case where he was um in criminal Cahoots
with individual one in that and my does
my memory serve me right yeah I think
there's involvement with them and I mean
I think he was also mentioned other
cases recently that involved I don't
know like conspiracy of solution and I
don't know you know like trying to
overtake the government crazy I know I
know but it's almost it's almost like
there's a two-tier jazz justice system
it's almost like if you have the money
and have the resources yeah you can get
yourself out of a situation you know
wait wait a second wait a second um it
looks like oh unless you're the kid of a
Democratic president then they will drag
you over the coast right right well
especially if there's a Republican
president also going to the United
States Attorney and attorney general
that would do that I mean I mean I'm not
gonna look I'm still waiting on those
goddamn Biden tapes guys I don't know
where they are they're somewhere out
there maybe they're buried with the
person that just happened to die you
know I I don't know I'm I'm still
curious where they are because Chuck
Grassley said he had them or then he
said he didn't have them and he didn't
hear them you know again it they really
go after one group and I'm not saying
you know you got people on both sides
that obviously have done stuff clearly
but at the same time let's
let's keep things equal here and how
we're we're trying to hold people
accountable or how we're trying to quote
unquote attack them if you're going to
go after someone on the Democratic side
like Hunter Biden and you're gonna make
outlandish claims like we got tapes we
got tapes we got tapes of the big guy we
got tapes of Hunter Biden you better
[__] show up
or you're [__] shut up right like the
difference between Hunter Biden tapes
and Donald Trump tapes is that Donald
Trump tapes actually exist and they're
in evidence
he admitted that it happened uh Justin t
Brown friend the show here says uh he's
responding to an axios headline it's
here says Hunter Biden a 53 year old son
a President Biden was charged Tuesday
with illegally possessing a handgun in
2018 in Failure to timely file and pay
taxes in 2017 to 2018. uh Justin's
comment is Hunter Biden pleads guilty to
being an American
I mean pretty [__] much man am I
wrong that's pretty much what he bled
guilty to it yeah I don't I don't want
to pay my [__] taxes I mean you know
who the [__] wants to pay taxes really I
mean it's not that's a good question
right I don't know anyone who does
well what about this guy what do you
think about this game maybe this guy
maybe this guy likes to pay taxes I
don't know uh let's let's see what he
has to say about the fairness the
fairness of this plea deal and socialism
worry about this case
based on the law zero
zero
presidential records acts plus the ACT
plus the Clinton case the Clinton case
which was won by Clinton as president
because he took he took tapes of leaders
in his size no that's not worried about
this case Okay so this isn't him
responding to the the allegations but
what it is what it is is him saying I'm
going all the way baby and I'm going to
win this I don't need no plea deal Texas
ball could could of Donald Trump have
negotiated a plea deal it's almost like
it's almost like there's evidence right
out in the open that his lawyers tried
to get him to negotiate a deal is that
Am I Wrong maybe I'm [__] on my
rocker here not even a plea deal Tony it
would have never come to a plea deal
he would have never caught charges if
he'd just given the [__] back
but no man he was Donald Trump and he
had plans for this this information he
he was the guy he can't handle he's
always done this Tony every time he gets
his ass in a crack
he tries to bully his way out of it
and he tried he tried to play a game of
chicken
with the Department of Justice and like
you were saying the Department of
Justice has unlimited resources they
don't give a damn about time if you want
to get into a pissing contest there is a
reason when you catch federal charges
you plea you plea do not try to fight
the doj you're going to lose and it's
going to hurt it's gonna freaking hurt
and Donald Trump is still to this day
thinking that he's going to out talk the
doj and Jack Smith last night can you
imagine Jack Smith sitting at home got
his little popcorn
notepad right here okay okay there's a
confession right there at 9 minutes and
37 seconds in Okay Okay click send that
to one of his lead prosecutors we're
gonna need this in court you know I mean
they just they
they've given Donald Trump plenty of
rope to hang himself they they they said
they they threw a little treat out and
they're like all right is he gonna take
it and then Chomp Chomp Chomp Chomp
right right on the face it's like
they're hanging felony carrots right
dude they're like hanging felony carrots
everywhere and he can't help it they
were like look maybe he's gonna go for
at least one of these how many and then
he's like I'm gonna go for all of them
right yeah it is it is usually it's like
a carrot on a stick but now it's okay
you know it's a Big Mac under a red
light not the same red light that you
use to tan Your Balls Like Tucker
Carlson but different one but it's that
same it's that same idea that they're
like hanging these treats out these
little chicken nuggets wait I think it's
the same I think it's the same light I
think the light that Donald Trump keeps
his Big Macs worm on the Big Mac Buffet
is the same light that Tucker Carlson
tanz's bowl with I think it's the same
one actually
let's just be factual here I'm just
saying I gotta stop the show for a
second Tony I apologize Public Service
Announcement when Josh Brolin came out
in favor of sun in your tank oh Texas
Paul
fell for it I went out gotta write your
sunburn on my tank and I waddled my
legged for a week folks you just cannot
do do not do this okay Public Service
Announcement when you're tanning your
tank what you need to do is you need to
use some lotion on that thing you
definitely don't want to tan your tank
without especially if it your taint is
now that doesn't feel right Tony I mean
rubbing the aloe down there you think
okay you know and it ain't like when you
put it on somewhere else man you know
you slap that cold stuff on down there
and try to
why Josh Brolin when he told you to uh
to uh get some get some sun on your hog
why Josh Brolin why did you listen to
him and Josh Brolin We Trust in Josh
Brolin
yeah going back to the days of Goonies
man I've been a Josh Brolin devotee
what's your I rooted for Thanos I was
rooting for Thanos the whole time
[Laughter]
oh man you know a great movie with Josh
Roland in it is the True Grit remake
that is such a good movie that he's in
and he played the exact right role in
that movie I didn't even see it coming
when I first saw it that he was going to
be that he was gonna play that role in
in True Grit but uh that's such a great
movie you're right Josh Brolin and I I
kind of was I'm not gonna lie I was
rooting for Thanos a little bit yeah I
mean [__] wow wow [__] him what are
you gonna do [__] him yeah he's some
kind of God you think you can just you
just run around smashing people with
your Hammer dude huh you think that way
you can [__] do huh well I'll show
you with this glove that's got some
jewels on it we'll get rid of him Thanos
put an ass whooping on Thor he did he
had to come back with friends he had to
come back with friends you know although
although I I will say I will say that
Thor did cut his [__] head off
but that was a little too late they had
to go back and fix it you know it
happens was it too late though they did
the whole Ant-Man Back to the Future
Theory and yeah but I'm not trying to
ruin Marvel movies or anything yeah yeah
it's been out since 2018. so and so as
about as long as they've been trying to
get Hunter Biden I guess yeah um I
didn't mean to derail the show there I
just wanted to give that PSA out there
do not tan your taint because I
guarantee you no matter how much they
love you Mrs Texas Paul loves me
worships the ground I walk on
and if you believe that I got a bridge
in San Francisco to sell you but
you will be stuck on your own putting
that aloe vera down there I guarantee
you ain't nobody helping you with that
so is the position that you tan your
tank the same position that you use to
put the aloe on is it the same exact
position just one to Tandem one to to
cool the tan is that the is that one in
here yeah it's not exactly same position
because once you turn once you toast
that tank
you cannot put your legs in that same
position you just can't oh okay I got
you God damn there's a I'm trying to
find a photo of Donald Trump I ain't no
photo of me doing that oh come on
photo I made of Donald Trump with said
ball Tanner but uh reeling yeah I gotta
I'll try and find it I'll try well let
me show you uh Brett Bear giving him a
little bit of tanning on his balls here
you know
um Chris Christie and Rhonda Santas have
it punched Donald Trump this hard yet
combined and Brett Baird does a
fantastic job of it here it's uh it's
incredible watch this in 2016 you said
that I'm going to surround myself with
only the best and most serious people
well I did do that that's a tremendous
look we had the best economy we've ever
had this time has ever seen your vice
president Mike Pence is running against
you yeah become ambassador to the United
Nations she's running against you your
former Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
said he's not supporting you you
mentioned National Security adviser John
Bolton he's not supporting you either
you mentioned attorney general Bill Barr
uh says you shouldn't be president again
uh it calls you the consummate
narcissist and the troubled man you
recently called and borrow a gutless pig
your second defense secretary is not
supporting you called you irresponsible
this week you and your White House
called your white house chief of staff
John Kelly weak and ineffective and born
with a very small brain you called your
acting white house chief of staff Mick
mulvania born loser you called your
first Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
dumb as a rock and your first defense
secretary James Mattis the world's most
overrated General you called your White
House Press Secretary Keith
and multiple times you've referred to
your transportation secretary Elaine
Chow that's the best thing
so
why did you hire all of them in the
first place because I I tend to one
y'all think Gabe's an angel he's not
okay so this this is some of the best
some of the best sparring and some of
the best just laying laying into Donald
Trump I've ever seen and yet no one has
laid into Donald Trump yet like this
yeah and it's not even a tough question
it's just like here are the things that
you originally said and then here are
the sound bites of you saying these
things about these specific high-ranking
officials that you had in your cabinet
how do you explain this it's it's not a
hard question it's a very simple
question you said this then you said
this
can you explain it right he's like oh
tender what shut the [__] up man you're
a [__] idiot dude and you're a
[__] uh two-faced backstabbing
uh document stealing cuck okay that's
what you are this this did you see the
look on his face so he was freaking
dying inside as Brett Bear was running
down that list because he you could see
the shock on his face when when bear
comes at him and he's like are you
really going to tell us questions to me
I mean are you really gonna do this and
as he just lists each of those
statements that these people made you
can just see him and he's shrinking
lower and lower and lower and lower in
his chair and that's I mean straight
fall off the camera
well maybe he should tan his balls more
here this is a real picture by the way
this is the real that Mar-A-Lago percent
real this was caught by a um one of one
of the guests there here he is uh
tanning is is this how you do it Texas
Falls
I'm all natural I throw a blanket out in
the back you know I live out in the
country nobody can see me you know what
I'm saying I got you I got you well
here's Donald Trump tanning his balls at
the and I mean hey look he's you know
he's got a decent decent spread going on
there to make sure he gets like all the
coverage right right well I mean you
don't want any part of your balls not to
be tanned if you're gonna contain them
yeah hey look like I said I there was a
photo and I told you it's real it's on
the internet and it's it's got to be if
it's on the internet It's gotta be
[__] real
um Donald Trump's spray tan
technician is the highest paid spray
tank spray tan technician in the country
they're the greatest they're the bravest
for sure yeah they're the bravest yeah
that the spray tan on the taint
will give you the exact same health
benefits as tanning your taint really
and therefore he does the old pull him
out of the way Mr Flappy
spray it on and that technician I
guarantee you it's a thousand dollars a
pop
really I think I think it's way more
probably I mean they got I mean
definitely definitely I mean like also
you know not a lot of not a lot of
pulling away has to be done to expose
the taint I don't I don't know I don't
know I think lifting that little
literally has nuts that bangs between
his knees he's got a little pecker and
huge set of balls I mean there ain't no
way it ain't like this throw some
feathers on it and you got yourself a
turkey like hog nuts I need that
[__] come on man that's why he's
so pissed off about Hunter Biden it's
because Hunter Biden's sausage to to
meatball ratio is much is much more
appealing uh to some people than what
his sausage to meatball ratio is I'm
sure that's why he's so mad at Hunter
Biden
that dude couldn't run naked if he had
to if he hadn't that [__] would twist
around and trip him up
like that I guarantee you is that why is
that why he is that why he drives the
golf cart and he's not he doesn't
actually walk on the golf course and
that's why he's like you know stammering
around because he don't want them balls
twisting around his legs and tripping
him up is that what you're saying
oh my god oh okay I gotta move on
speaking of taints
speaking of Tanks here's Chris Christie
this morning uh trying to land a punch
Chris man you used to be so [__] good
at this listen Chris Christie if you
want call me I'll [__] try to work
you up into a just a father from from
foam from I I don't know I'm [__]
Chrome who cares I I'm [__]
distracted by the uh the old hog nuts
someone don't please don't make to
please don't make that graphic please do
not do that the internet does not what
do you think what do you think old games
working on right now
so Chris Christie this morning is trying
to land a punch and Chris honestly if
you want just call me I'll get you
pissed off enough that you can that you
can start Landing punches like you used
to here here's he is trying to land the
same punch that Brett landed last night
that he didn't think of because Chris
Christie's lost it I think I think he
knows he's in trouble and last night I
think the worst moment for him was that
talking about the fact that he just
didn't have time uh to go through these
boxes well in response to a grand
tourism yet he told the government and
had his lawyer certify that he had
returned all of the documents that were
responsive to The subpoena that is
obstruction of justice and it appears to
me last night as a former prosecutor
that he had he admitted obstruction of
justice on the air last night to Brett
Bear I can tell you this his lawyers
this morning are jumping out of whatever
window they're near okay so Chris
Christie is is doing the wrong thing
here um and here's what he's doing wrong
Chris Christie is trying to act like
he's a United States Attorney here and
he's campaigning as if he's a United
States Attorney and I hate to break it
to him that's not you're not going to
win man you're not even going to get
fourth place probably with this attitude
you need to drop the United States
Attorney bit and you need to go all in I
mean [__] balls deep into the idea
that Donald Trump is not a person you
want in the White House stop talking
about the case stop talking about that
[__] just throw punches at him like
Brett Bear did Brett Bear did an
excellent job Bret bear wasn't like oh
well you admitting the crimes here in
this interview is going to be really
complicated for you and your attorneys
no he's like all right keep going [__]
yeah here you want a bigger shovel and
oh by the way you're a dumbass because
you said this and now you said this this
and this you contradict yourself all the
time dummy I mean he landed really solid
punches that um these these Republican
candidates for the nomination uh could
learn from here's why one of the moments
that Chris Christie was talking about
there where
um Brett Bear basically gets him to
admit that yeah I was waving around
[__] nuclear plans to uh Iran's
nuclear Brands and plans to attack it's
[__] wild [__] again this is a wild
time to be alive listen to this [__]
in 2016 you said that I'm going to
surround myself with only the best and
most serious people well I did one
that's the wrong one that's the one I
just played yeah come on Tony there's so
many come on there's so many of them
what do you want me to do let me find
the one that I'm looking for here
where's the one I'm looking for
God damn it I don't know dude
here it is but I will say I will say all
if if people I mean like you know people
could take their cues from Fox News
honestly at this point I mean like
you've got Brett Baer saying these
things and again it's not a crazy
question it's not a complicated question
it's like you said this
you said this which is the complete
opposite explain it right and this isn't
the first time that we've seen Trump say
something then tweet the opposite tweet
something then say the opposite say
something and say the opposite or
whatever right like there's some
basically the same goes there's always a
tweet right or there's always a clip or
there's always a statement of some sort
which will go completely opposite to
what uh
Donald Trump has previously said
and people need to just continue to push
on that and this is just one example
right this is like these are the people
that you said were the best these are
the people that you put in charge to run
this country and now you're saying that
there are milk toast or they're terrible
or they're incompetent or they're dumb
or they're this or that or some you know
derogatory racial slur or whatever it
might be
and they just need to continue to push
that to say like you cannot trust this
man you should not trust him with your
money with your vote with anything he
will backstab you he will betray you he
will throw you under the goddamn bus to
save himself and people need to continue
to push this idea that you can never
believe or trust what he says ever
well here he here he is I don't know
maybe we can trust what he says let's
listen to admit to [__] felonies
right here on Fox News this is great
on it but according to the indictment
you will hear about I don't want to
dwell on it 21st 2021 after you're no
longer president and you were recorded
saying that you had a document detailing
a plan of attack on another country that
was prepared by the U.S military for you
when you were president the Iran attack
plan you remember that
ready you were recorded it's in a
document okay I had lots of paper I had
copies of newspaper articles I had
copies of magazines I said specifically
a quote you're quoted on the recording
saying the document was secret adding
that you could have Declassified it
while you were president but quote now I
can't you know this is still secret
highly okay so I wanna I wanna say
something I'm gonna stop here the reason
why is because and and I know we point
in all the time me and Gabe go in these
Twitter spaces now
um after this case after years of rained
on this case one of the first narratives
they were trying out in this space was
that oh listen no one said what the
document was that he was pointing out
what if what if Gabe he was pointing at
a New York Times article talking about
this document what if he was doing that
and he's trying to work that material in
this interview but he didn't practice it
enough yeah he didn't practice enough he
really [__] that up well you can also
I mean like those people the people in
in these Twitter spaces or the people
that are preparing The Narrative of like
oh we don't know what the document is
that could have been whatever right
classify this classify that I mean even
though we knew that some of these
documents were so pivotal to National
Security and nuclear secrets is that
they could not even go into detail about
them on the actual cert the the uh the
search warrant right and what they had
retrieved they couldn't even indicate
that on the indictment what they had to
do was they had to say like oh this is
this from this I mean you know
um
uh you know uh Fred woman talked about
it yesterday right like this idea that
there were some documents on there that
were so important and so top secret that
they could not even indicate what they
were
right
and these people in these Twitter spaces
and other other spots that are trying to
create this narrative like oh we don't
know what these documents are we don't
know what to do we don't we don't guys
do we really know if he was trying to do
something malicious with the documents
like what you know what was it Iran this
Iran that like whatever it might be
newspaper clippings and it's like
okay well give it a week and uh let's
see what he says himself the problem is
is that the indictment says there's at
least four people that were privy to
this right and they're recording but
let's let's listen to grandpa
um uh dig a bigger hole for himself the
confidential and the indictment starts
the recording and the testimony from
people in the room saying you showed it
to people there that day so you say on
this is just the opposite that you can't
declassify it so why have it what I said
when I said that I couldn't be
classified now that's because I wasn't
president I I never made any bones about
that when I'm not president I can't eat
less if I that's what you said you did I
said no no I said I couldn't do it
there was no document that was a massive
amount of papers and everything else
talking about Iran and other things okay
I I just want to say my my hope is in
this whole thing that once we do go to
trial because there's news that uh Canon
Gannon the judge in the case to set the
trial for August 14th uh Kyle Chaney has
reported it uh I might show that to you
here but uh he says Kyle Cheney says
just in judge Cannon set preliminary
trial schedule for Trump case beginning
August 14th I told you that earlier but
it Kyle also says don't spend a lot of
time on this it won't hold it's not
intended to and that's that's the truth
there but here's the thing here's the
thing here's what I want when this thing
finally goes to trial mm-hmm you know I
want more than anything in the world oh
my God it would just be I I mean it
would put the last eight years because
it's gonna be eight maybe ten by the
time we get to that point
just a cherry on top of the [__]
if Donald Trump decides to testify in
his own [__] trial right and he's
sitting on the stand and Jack Smith gets
to question this [__] about this
little time period of this recording
after everything that Jack Smith knows
can you imagine how full that diaper is
going to be on oh yeah and oh my God
there's nothing that will please me more
listen if we're gonna do reality
trumpster Fire TV let's do that like
let's do it properly like that is the
proper way to really for this guy to to
destroy himself is an open court trying
to testify in front of Jack Smith let's
keep going let's keep uh seeing how many
more crimes he admits to here and you
know man
yeah
go ahead no you know how delicious it's
going to be actually because it's going
to be Eileen cannon that the the the the
doj the prosecutor from the doj is going
to object
Eileen cannons is going to have to sit
there on the bench and explain to
Grandpa Poopypants
that this is not the law that what he
just said is not true
and you need to disregard it because
it's a lie and he's going to have to sit
there in front of his judge that he
appointed and listened to that [__] and
he's going to freaking die he's going to
he's not going to be able to contain
himself if he has
anyone in his life that loves him
they will hold him down and make him
understand that his lawyers speak for
him and he needs to shut the hell up
wait wait wait I know you like to tan
your tank because of what Josh Brolin
said and I understand that you were
rooting for
Thanos because Josh Brolin but did you
just say Donald Trump has someone in his
life that loves him is that what you
said I said if okay I didn't say holy
[__] because normally love is like a
two-way street like you have to love
someone for them you know to love but I
there could be unconditional love from
someone to Donald Trump I highly [__]
doubt it though but let's listen to more
crimes than he admits to here it's um
it's wild [__] about the documents that
he claims he didn't have maybe did have
I don't know who knows who could tell my
hands are small my skin is orange but
that was not a document I didn't have a
document per se there was nothing to
Declassified these were newspapers per
se what what was it I didn't have a
document per se
look guys I didn't sexually assault her
per se right that's what Donald Trump
said he's like I didn't commit this
crime per se right he I'm sure he uses
the same language when it came to uh uh
EJ and Carol when it came to that phone
call I didn't make a phone phone call
per se right
I didn't ask for him to overturn the
election per se I didn't I didn't
artificially inflate the value of my
businesses per se right no
well that's what were those what were
those things that you turned over yeah
per se before they had to per se raid
your home to get the other things that
they found per se that were hidden in
boxes well I wouldn't say hidden in
boxes per se because they were in your
freaking ballroom and in your bathroom
what were those things that were made of
paper that happened
per se what per se were those yeah well
let's let's see if we can find out what
they were because he [__] says it out
loud here type of stores magazine stores
yeah and articles I'm just saying what
the indictment says well the recording
and the people in the room who testified
very dishonest people they're thugs
they're thugs if you look at what
they've done to other people what
they've done to and overturned in the
U.S Supreme Court these are thugs the
suggestion was that you wanted this as
evidence that the military the chairman
of the Joint Chiefs General milley had
preemptively sent you plans for a
possible attack on Iran and that you
didn't order that to happen that's the
signature I never ordered it to happen
no but that's why you wanted the
document I don't I don't think I've ever
seen a document from Millie Millie
frankly was incompetent the last one I'd
want to attack with as my leader would
be Millie that I can tell you
per se per se look he wasn't my military
advisor per se but I he was in some
capacity an advisor of the military yeah
he wasn't the military advisor Donald
Trump okay Don Jr Eric Eric Trump you
know there are my children per se
let me ask you you know a lot of people
give Eric [__] for being the dumbest
Trump I mean after last night's
interview there's a stiff competition
here you know at first I was like are
they his kids and now I'm like yeah
they're all [__] idiots right these
are the kids he is related
apparently at one point they put us do
you think maybe to go down that
conspiracy whole rabbit hole do you
think maybe because you know fox has
always been all in they are an arm of
the of the GOP do you think maybe just a
little bit that that that you know
Murdoch sat down with Brett Bear and
said
kill him kill him on live television
yeah so that he sees what he's going to
face in court and maybe listens to his
lawyers are you you think you think
that's a good strategy I don't know he's
never listened to his I don't think
Donald Trump has ever listened to anyone
in his life other than Donald Trump
right
so yeah he stands in front of the mirror
and says this [__] or do you think it's
just literally Tom Tom Fenton on the
phone with him like no no you're good
trust me I got all the legal beagle on
it you're good don't worry about it go
on Fox News admit to your crime you'll
be fine you'll be fine it'll be cool
yeah I could imagine like Tom fitting on
the phone [__] you know injecting
himself with some [__] steroids
trying on shirts that are three sides
too small grinding down his teeth for
meth whatever it might be on the phone
yeah like just perspirating through he's
like which one am I gonna sweat through
next on the phone with Donald Trump
being like look you don't got to do
anything for them man you're the man man
you do your own thing you set your own
rules you write through your own laws
right the president has unilateral power
Donald Trump they have unilateral power
and with unilateral power you can do
anything he's like
I'm just telling you I found this on the
internet I found this on here this has
got to be real watch this
first of all I won in 2020 by a lot okay
let's get that straight I won in 2020.
let's get that straight
everything that you want to look at you
take a look at truth to vote where they
have people stuffing the ballot boxes on
tapes or Mr President
let's go to Lisa FBI Twitter let's go to
recent the 51 agents all corrupt stuff
understand about it
but that's cheating when they lost the
2020 election uh Brett did I take a look
at all of this stuff now let's you take
a look at all of the things including
things like the 51 intelligence ages
there were recounts in all of the Swing
States
the only thing not real about this is
that they should have put a straight
jacket on this guy yeah slack and
lunatic I swear to God I kept waiting
during this entire interview for a
freaking Spirit you know like a
spearhead on a chain to fly out of Brett
Bear's arm and impale Donald Trump and
then scream get over here
fatalities yeah I mean
[Music]
I think I think this could be a scene
out of that they're uh they're working
on Mortal Kombat 2 right now really this
could be a featured scene where
someone's like oh yeah this is what we
should do this is moved
get over here
um so this morning at the White House
but I'm a statement you know let's go to
the real president the one that was
actually elected oh we're um yeah so
they they put out a statement this
morning about this Hunter Biden uh plea
deal thing uh the White House and Kyle
Griffin has a report here says White
House spokesperson Ian Sam says the
president and the first lady love their
son oh and support I mean unlike the
last president he didn't he didn't even
really he doesn't even know his name
right and support him and as he
continues to rebuild his life we will
have no further comment so they
basically the president and the first
lady have said look we love our son we
understand he did some wrong it looks
like the prosecutors are going to come
after him and that's just the way it's
going to be now my question was so
they won't do they're not going to be
doing a podcast episode on this one
haven't they learned anything from magas
because that's like ah come on that's
their first reaction don't you know yeah
when this kind of [__] happens Donald
Trump's like whoa I'm charging 37
felonies that they can prove in an
indictment well I'm gonna go on TV and
tell them why they're right like okay
and Hunter Biden
Hunter Biden's uh all his the people
surrounding him including the president
including the first lady including his
siblings uh including everyone that he's
had contact with have kept their [__]
mouth shut yeah about Hunter Biden uh
specifically Hunter Biden himself has
kept his [__] mouth shut we haven't
really seen uh since he released his
book any really kind of public
statements from Hunter Biden right
because here's the thing he doesn't owe
anyone well any of that but but the
thing is is that you are innocent until
proven guilty right right just like
Donald Trump is and listen maga maga
listen to me I know there's some haters
here listening because you love to hate
me I get it I want you to keep coming
invite your [__] friends you [__]
morons you boneheads maybe you'll learn
a thing or two but listen to me Donald
Trump has the ability today today for
his attorneys he'd call him up right
[__] now I know he's got him on
[__] speed dial he call him up if he
has attorney does he still have attorney
anyways you can call the attorneys that
he may or may not have that he may or
may not pay and he could tell him look I
want to make a deal let's sit down down
with the prosecutors and the special
counsel and the in in the U.S attorney
U.S attorneys that are in charge of this
case and I'll make a deal he could make
a plea deal today just like Conor Biden
did now he should have done it a long
time ago like Texas Paul said right none
of this would have become criminal but
really even up until the point after the
[__] raid when the raid happened he
had the opportunity then he knew it was
serious he knew they had a [__]
criminal goddamn search warrant search
his [__] property they were gonna
keep it a secret folks he's the one the
reason why we knew about it is because
of him because he couldn't keep his
[__] mouth shut do you know I bet I
bet in years to come we're gonna find
out that the FBI and the doj went and
they raided Hunter's [__] house they
raided his [__] house they took
evidence they took [__] from him and I
bet they used that against him in this
case to get him to take this plea deal
my
and you know why we don't know a [__]
thing about it because he kept his
[__] mouth shut he kept his [__]
mouth shut just like Donald Trump should
have kept his [__] mouth shut and he
wouldn't have been in this situation but
that you know coming back to the
original question is like do they not
learn anything from America on that and
they're not going to do a podcast
episode
Republicans only know how to grift and
complain and whine about the very issue
very problem that they're in trouble for
right and then by doing so they make it
worse they might make some money here
and there but in doing so they're gonna
post about it you got [__] George
Santos Donald Trump Matt Gates marger
Taylor green Lauren bobert all of these
people can't help themselves but say
something that reveals more
about the situation they're in that we
didn't know about we weren't privy to
but they decide that the only thing
that's going to set them free is to
project more about the things that they
are guilty of right
and so they get super mad when God
forbid a loving mother and a loving
father say about their son that's been
in the public eye in public scrutiny and
attacks and attacks and attacks by the
Republican party to say hey
we love and we support our son and we're
here for him every step of the way so
that he can get better it is no
different than the same voicemail that
was left from Joe Biden on Hunter
Biden's phone where he was like hey guy
I'm calling just want to check in on you
I love you and I care about you and I
just want to make sure you're okay what
did Republicans do when they got that
voicemail they're like oh man look at
this [__] he's calling his son what's up
that's a [__] [__] beta move calling
this something like he cares about him
oh God damn he's such a he's such an
addict continue to attack Joe Biden and
Hunter Biden only for a simple voicemail
that said I care about you and I'm here
if you want to talk
and the same thing is said here and
Republicans oh oh god oh oh god oh and
they get all [__] in their [__]
tighty whities
and all fall [__] pissed off because
they yearn for the very thing that Joe
Biden and Jill Biden are doing for
Hunter Biden which is just being
supportive you know that that that
brings up a good point because
if if there was a Republican president
and their their children were in legal
Peril and they controlled the Department
of Justice my guess is that they would
do everything in their power to protect
their children from the the Department
of Justice and felony and even
misdemeanor charges on taxes Joe Biden
did nothing besides just love his son he
knew he's in trouble the bare minimum
the bare minimum he knew he was he knew
he was in trouble he knew he couldn't
protect him because if he did these
people would play stupid political games
and it'd be even worse for for his his
son Hunter it would be even worse for
him so he he just let Hunter take the
lick and Hunter took the lick and he's
gonna take the lick that's what a plea
deal is folks I don't know if you know
this but it is damn it is damn harder to
[__] take a plea deal
um when when you're dealing with this
type of [__] when you're dealing with
several Federal felonies trust me it's
it's difficult to make that decision
to go to prison or to be punished
because going to trial you're not you're
not making the decision you don't make
the decision rather you're punished or
not a jury makes that decision you don't
get to make that decision but in a plea
deal you're making that decision you're
choosing to punish yourself so the idea
that that somehow this is some sort of
[__] thing where ju because really
honestly if it really was that big of a
deal to moglodytes and you [__]
people wanted to get all what Joe Biden
pardon him then well I didn't pardon him
then yeah he could pardon his son why
couldn't he he's got unilateral power
Texas Paul the president United States
could declassify information with his
[__] mind and he can pardon anyone he
wants even his political allies even
people who he is in their [__]
Federal cases they're convicted of is
individual one like Roger Stone so why
wouldn't Jill Biden pardon Hunter Biden
it's his son [__] it just pardon him
pardon him from these crimes before he
even gets to the bench to plead to these
charges now that Joe Biden knows it he
can just do it with his mind he doesn't
even need to write it out Texas Paul
because he's the president of the United
States he's the most powerful being ever
in the history of ever ever what uh wait
quick question though yeah um you know I
was just thinking about something just
kind of sure dawned on me
so do you remember how Republicans
wanted to abolish and defund the IRS
yeah well if the IRS never existed oh
that then wouldn't that mean that Hunter
Biden would be able to get away with the
crimes they won't just plead it to they
want to get rid of the FBI and the ATF
too that would get rid of that gun
charge Texas Paul what do you think man
this is I think I think we're onto
something here
okay this is crazy if you've got one you
got rid of one and you got rid of the
other then yeah no crimes right you know
what I I think this is giving more
validity of why Joe Biden because of the
weaponization of government the
weaponization of the doj the IRS the ATF
and the FBI I think this is a reason why
Joe Biden should pardon should pardon
Hunter Biden that's what they're saying
about Trump Texas Paul they're making
this argument about Trump that the
weaponization of government is the
reason why these nominees are these
candidates for the nominee and
Republican party need to need to show
their loyalty and they need to promise
that if they win the presidency they'll
pardon Donald Trump I think it's the
same logic the same reasoning that
democrats should be using for Joe Biden
to Pardon his son don't you like
no no no no no no
I get you logic all right we're trying
to bait him into it we can't get him we
can't get him I you know and I'll tell
you why you were talking about he's
going to take his licks if you
have never tried to help someone you
love through an addiction
it is hell because everything it's all
counterintuitive it's all asked
backwards and upside down
you know I guarantee you when Joe Biden
helped his son and he helped he helped
Hunter Biden get into the Navy he did he
was beyond the age requirements he had
to file out a way to file a waiver
he helped him everywhere he could to get
in the Navy because I'm sure he thought
that was going to straighten his son out
and it ended up being one of the worst
things he could have ever done because
he got caught doing cocaine
and kicked out of the Navy and it's just
everything you think as a parent that
you're doing to help
your kids you're enabling them and that
is why because Joe Biden has learned
with Hunter Biden that he has to deal
with these problems on his own there
will never be a pardon coming from Joe
Biden not even out the door not even at
the end because he loves his son
and and after you've helped someone with
an addiction problem long enough you've
learned you learned Sometimes the best
help is just
crossing your arms
and saying I'm sorry I love you
I'm sorry this is happening to you and
that's it leave it there and I don't
mean to bring the mood down or anything
like that but
just to try to bait you into uh saying
that Joe Biden should uh should pardon
100 by I'm gonna keep saying that he
should pardon him because this is a
weaponization of the government I truly
believe it it is a United States
Attorney that was appointed by Donald
Trump to prosecute Joe Biden his
weaponization of the doj the FBI the ATF
the IRS which defund all of them because
they're coming after Hunter Biden and
Joe Biden should pardon him I don't know
and and you know what they're going to
say that's dumb that's stupid Tony I
can't believe you'd say that like that's
exactly what you're you're saying you
[__] idiot like that's exactly what
you're saying if what I'm saying sounds
stupid maybe you should go [__] say
what you're saying into the mirror
um speaking of dumb [__] man I
don't want to skip over this story okay
I think I know what you're gonna play
yeah this well no this is this is uh you
know yeah I just gotta I just got a
notification yeah they got 40 uh they're
estimated to have 40 hours of air left
left in that little windowless Submarine
that's controlled by a goddamn Xbox
controller tell me tell me tell me what
the [__] this is about because okay
going to the Titanic right so there's
this there's a couple things here
there's one submarine the picture yeah
this is the submarine so this is Ocean
Gate right and there are five people and
you pay 250 000 wait wait wait wait wait
they named it Ocean Gate yeah I know I
thought this was like I thought this was
like there's a controversy yeah yeah no
I know I know it's one of those moments
it before it's one of those it's one of
those things where they named it and
then it's kind of like oh look it came
to be
so basically this this submarine here it
has no windows right it's got four
monitors that have cameras all around it
you can't see out of it like a normal
submarine that they've previously taken
down to the Titanic has Windows that you
can view out you know port and starboard
hole yeah and you can see like oh look
I'm here and I'm here by the uh by the
Titanic or I'm over here wherever right
so you can know the uh I quit building
them that way though on purpose though
they quit putting windows in them on
purpose because James Cameron's sub that
window cracked I mean he was this close
to absolutely die in the worst way
possible because yeah because they're
going they're going two and a half wait
wait wait go go back James Cameron you
mean when he was preparing to do the
movie Titanic this is when well not only
that there's the there was the movie and
then he also did it happen during the
movie or did it happen during the like
Disney like 3D Titanic experience when
he was going down into the Challenger
Deep to set the record down because
they're going two and a half there
there's a graphic on Twitter that I'm
sure you can easily find that shows you
you because they're going two and a half
miles down to the floor of the ocean
where the Titanic is where the Titanic
is and each part they say okay at this
pressure this is what it would be like
at this pressure this is what it would
be like right and then they mean like
the intensity of it the intensity of
what happens let's say if a hole were to
just all of a sudden puncture the Little
Submarine what would happen to it at
that point why are human beings in this
thing anyways why aren't they just
sending cameras down there why why
aren't we because it's a whole fight why
do they think they're [__] because
this is one of those things like I want
to go to space and I want to go to Sea
and I want to do this all stuff right
like I don't know I saw someone online
that was like can we just stop [__]
with Mother Nature because just what are
you doing you got the technology send
the technology down there and look at it
now I do I do want to say because um uh
I've watched a few documentaries on the
Titanic and then people going down there
and and it's not going to be too much
longer that we're going to have to like
explore it because that motherfucker's
just falling apart right and yeah and it
was like a couple I forget how long ago
there was a special that was done I
think by CBS or whatever and they were
talking about how it is
um the guy who runs uh Ocean Gate was
talking about how my God I can't okay so
people are here let me give you context
people aren't it sounds like people
aren't sure about the story is can you
go back to the photo yeah all right so
this and I'll try to find the video at
the same time but okay
basically there are five people and they
pay 250 000 to go down take this guy
right here this Little Submarine down
this is a rich people thing yeah those
are rich people a lot of them one of
them one of them is a billionaire and
the other four people have been uh
identified as dude they take this
all the way down to the bottom so they
can explore and you know check out the
Titanic first you know first hand except
they can't see it through it right there
you're looking at it through a camera
now let me find I'll try and find a
video right now but basically this
Little Submarine is controlled by a
Bluetooth
game controller okay
a Bluetooth game controller and they
have a few on on you know in the in the
in the vest imagine the pitch deck for
this for these rich [__] so
yeah so basically what happened is they
went down and then they just kind of
lost track of where this Ocean Gate sub
went why what internet connection were
they using well that's a funny story so
it's connected to starlink okay well
wait we've heard that before what is
starlink starlink would be the internet
uh uh company that you know satellite
internet that is offered by
Elon Musk oh hmm so yeah uh this is the
yeah I don't I hate that I hate to be
this guy but
that's kind of been debunked because
starlink will only penetrate a few
meters into the water
um maybe that's the problem
and this guy man this guy peddles a lot
of lies he peddles a lot of lies every
day on Twitter but from his personal
account about Twitter and about what
he's gonna do and what he's not gonna do
this guy makes all kinds of promises to
people that he can't [__] keep
because he's a stupid [__] he's a
stupid little [__] this Elon Musk and
he's he's not as smart as anyone thinks
he is people who are really smart then
around him Gabe's tested this before
like actual rocket scientists that work
at at his company say this guy's a dumb
[__] like he doesn't he can't
comprehend this stuff so it's not
outside the realm that he would sell the
lie that yeah this this thing could go
that far sure why not who gives a [__]
but there's a lot there's a lot that's
going on Beyond this so if you click the
first video this begins to give you an
idea and then I'll I'll update this one
from this one from Tim is that yeah yeah
the CEO is this the CEO of Ocean Gate
no I don't think so
and let me let me let me get the back
here so it wants his CEO oh no no it
says this guy is the CEO of the company
oh okay okay so here is um here's the
video now is this the actual submarine
this is the actual submarine and they're
giving you a tour of of what it's like I
I'm not I haven't played this yet but
the still shot looks like a VHS from the
1990s I'm just yeah so this is I think
it's pointing that out a CBS uh it was a
CBS kind of like right but doesn't this
look like it's Texas Paul doesn't it
look like this is like from you know 60
Minutes uh from the 1990s like a VHA
step where you I know I'm just saying
let's let's watch surface an
experimental submersible vessel that has
not been approved or certified by any
regulatory body and could result in
physical injury disability emotional
trauma or death
where do I find
wait a second I didn't see that coming I
did not see that coming so you're saying
this is one of the guys that's inside
that moment no no this is not one of the
guys this is one of the people that work
for I think it's CBS I know but he's
pointing out the fact that like none of
this has been there's no regulation
around this there's no approval there's
no one that went through and was like
great you got this this this and what
you'll find is we play this video and
there's another video I have okay we'll
give you more context to how this how
this submarine uh might make you feel a
little bit sketch about how it's put
together it reminds me of the meme take
my money now it sort of reminds you okay
let's let's keep listening
oh
take your shoes off that's customary
okay
wow
inside the sub has about as much room as
a minivan so this is not your
grandfather's submersible
we only have one button that's it it
should be like an elevator you know it
shouldn't take me the Titan is the only
five person sub in the world that can
reach Titanic depths 2.4 miles below the
sea
it's also the only one with a toilet
sort of and yet I couldn't help noticing
how many pieces of this sub seemed
improvised we can use these
off-the-shelf components
we run the whole thing with this game
controller
seems like
it seems like don't go to now go to the
second link I sent you okay and this is
highlighting the game it's great why
haven't we we should have been talking
about this the whole time not the hunter
buying story I'm sorry this is this is
way better this is way better oh no
[__] way or you [__] me so this is
the game controller that uh that was
shown in there right the only adjustment
was that gray one that they added like
these longer extension uh for the thumbs
right it's only 30 bucks yeah I mean
it's really they have a few of these on
board but they're all Bluetooth
connected and those are the in case you
know a redundancy if one of them fails
or or dies out then yeah that way you're
not stuck at the bottom of the ocean
with only like 40 hours left but this is
how this is what they've hacked together
to say like oh you are able to use this
game controller to control the submarine
where you are the good news is wait the
good news is this it works with Windows
me Windows 98 Windows 2000 and the the
current upgrade Windows XP P that's the
good news about this controller I mean
so there's uh I think it was CBS and to
give people context I think it was CBS
uh they did their own
years ago uh sometime after Titanic uh
they went down with I think with James
Cameron and they went down to go check
it out
what happened though is they went to
where the rudder was okay in the in at
the end of the at the end of the Titanic
and then they're like great we saw this
part look at everything's like degrading
I'm trying to find that video I can't
right now but they're like look it it's
falling apart and they tried to back out
and what happened was they got caught in
between the propeller right and where
they were at the back trying to move
back and forth and they even showed a
DOT like so they were stuck
they were in this in this part of the
Titanic yeah and the and the reporter
was like I went down there years ago and
we also got stuck and almost died
because we couldn't get out so that's
that's showing you right there with with
people who are professionals who went
down there anything can happen right
anything can go wrong and that was with
professionals who were there this is
with a scenario where you have
I don't know who else is in there that's
actually the you know the person that's
in charge that's commanding this and
controlling this this submarine
but if that could happen to a group that
also by the way you know was trained for
it
how does that Trend you know how does
that translate to this because again
nobody knows what happened right nobody
knows kind of where they are and they
have people they didn't put any how then
they put in like tracking on well that's
the big question right and I don't know
if they have but I can tell you right
now is it tethered is it tethered no no
it's it's not tethered they don't have
two and a half miles worth or I guess I
mean you'd have to have even more right
you'd have 2.4 miles down and then you
have whatever the you know the length of
the the Titanic is in two separate
sections because they're broken half
remember so you have to remember that
it's you know you'd have to probably
allow for like five miles but you can't
have it tethered because what if it gets
caught somewhere right right you have no
way to unhook it yeah so that's that's
the issue that's there here's here's the
controller in the video just a still
shot you can see they just added bigger
nipples is all they did yeah so they
have these bigger nipples and I don't
know if that's just to make sure that
you I don't know make it easier or what
have you but
basically these people according to this
recent report is they've got 40 hours
left of oxygen so they've got CO2
scrubbers and they've got oxygen tanks
in there and there were people that were
even on Fox news last night on Jesse
Waters and the guy was like
uh I one of the people that are in there
he's like I I worked with them before
he's like but I also don't have a lot of
Hope right now which are they well I
mean what not gives them not a lot of
Hope what's the is because I guess
they've got they've got their search and
rescue happening right now and they're
working with the Navy and they are
unable to locate where they are
not another vessel to go down and rescue
them two miles underneath the [__]
service yeah
I mean I mean there's just not a there's
not a [__] machine that you just you
[__] out and you just go down now you
know you know what you remember the um
the was it a soccer team that was
trapped that was yeah it was this it was
a team it was the 13 players that got
trapped someone tweet Elon Musk and see
if he can if he's smart enough to come
up with the device that he can save
these people I bet he could come well if
anyone tells him no he'll just call them
a pedo so that's true what's this last
video here what's this one is this this
is uh
I'm trying to remember I just I think
it's might be the same one or but you
can play well let's play it pieces of
this sub seemed yeah yeah it's more of
the same we can use these offices it
seemed improvise let's go back up here
so this is what he's talking about
improvise because it's like oh my God
like they're just drawn with sharpies on
this thing
like there's no official labeling or
anything and oh my god what the [__] is
wrong with these people now I I I'm
I remember the Titanic movie do you guys
remember the Titanic movie with the lady
in the in the The Jewel and the Heart of
the Ocean yeah
hey go come on [__] yeah she threw it
off the edge and then and then you know
and yeah I mean a great story with
Leonardo DiCaprio he drew when she was
naked I mean that's kind of part of the
that perpetuates oh that's what you
remember okay well yeah I mean come on I
was a teenager yeah I remember going to
see the Titanic and I'm sitting there
and a pair of boobs come up on the
screen I I remember that and I was like
this is a really good movie we should
come back and see it again I mean I
remember that yeah of course I do but
the thing about the movie is when even
in the movie they send down
um a submarine but it's it doesn't have
anybody in it yeah it's a motorized uh
machine or a submarine that can explore
the area without having to raise
people's lives and it kind of makes
sense because it is two miles under the
ocean yeah if you lose it you know yeah
you lost a really expensive piece of
equipment but no one died I mean it kind
of makes sense but the idea that you
would put this [__] Cobble this
machine together right and then put
human beings in it and the only reason
why the these human beings are in it is
because they can afford to be in it
right no experience no [__] no
nothing they just signed a check and
signed the disclosure right like
I don't know I mean I think natural
selection is real I mean they want to
launch rockets into space go ahead get
in your own rocket go into space you
dumb [__] oh you want to get
into a submarine and go three miles
under the surface of the ocean and you
want to get trapped down there and you
want to die within you know two days hey
go for it yeah sure just that we should
have a dumb tax though that's all I'm
trying to say like if you're gonna do
stupid [__] like this it should cost you
like 250 is that how much it costs 250
000 yeah that ain't actually ain't a bad
price for the ticket you know to get in
your own coffin and send it to the
bottom of the ocean that's not a bad
price but here's the thing here's the
thing is that we should have a tax on
that right if you're gonna do stupid
[__] like this like yeah 250 Grand but
hey we're gonna tax you nine million
dollars well that's I mean that's that's
why I also think that the people should
be taxed you know when it comes to like
uh the blue origin and SpaceX and uh you
know Richard Branson's I forget what
they are but anyone who leaves you know
because their whole goal is space
exploration and and consumer uh travel
around you know into the in space I
think that I believe that there should
be uh much like when you pay a toll
right to leave an area and come back in
you should be paying a tax to leave our
our planet for a moment in time and come
back right
um and I don't think it's crazy to to to
you know to charge those things but
actually there's one last graphic I want
to show just to give people an
understanding of what the pressure is
like as you go deeper
yeah I sent you a link that last one uh
while I'm pulling this up Texas Paul
explain to me why this isn't elon's
fault
fault is he Frozen
um I they I think the story was debunked
in what they came up with was that uh
they use starlink on the ship
but starlink won't penetrate deep enough
into the water the signal won't for them
to actually use it on the submarine the
submarine is on its own
um
well that makes sense that makes sense
that I tell you I've got a good Hunch
what happened yeah go ahead yeah yeah
well if you look at the cameras if you
go back to the picture of the of the
actual submarine with the cameras you'll
notice that a lot of the camera
equipment isn't round
um there's a reason these submarines are
round
like that I mean it's it's the only
shape that will withstand these kind of
forces you know that will act with
itself I think that they probably lost
their cameras
um down there and then they were stuck
with in being in the situation as you
were just describing you can't just blow
ballast and and Float back up if you're
near the ship you'll hang up it
God damn that's not a bad Theory that's
not a bad I mean it sounds like from
what I was reading it sounds like they
lost the vessel loss contact about an
hour and 45 minutes into its dive of the
wreck how long was the dive supposed to
be
uh I don't know I mean I mean well I
guess
I guess in theory as long as you want it
to be right uh because you have all of
these CO2 scrubbers and you have oxygen
tanks so you know I don't know if there
was a scheduled time in which year they
were supposed to be like great you're
only down there for five hours right
and again you know the question you know
you might ask is like why wasn't a
tether to the boat it's because you know
if you're going to exp okay the
difference I would say of sending
something that is Tethered right
tethered would mean that you're limited
to be just scanning the outside right
you're just they want to go in that
[__] yeah yeah so I don't know if
they're I will I mean it's decently
sized it's they said it's as big that
one portion of it is as big as like a
van which then you've got the outside
portions of it so that's even larger so
I don't know how well they could go into
it I'm sure you know
the whole of it might be exposed in some
parts but again very dangerous because
this thing has been
um breaking down since 19 what is it
1914 right or something I'm trying to
remember what year 19 1912 uh 1914 I
think uh correct me if I'm wrong but um
the the reason like 19 it was 1998 when
Leonardo DiCaprio did the movie oh right
no that was 1997. I'm just I'm just
giving you [__] here's this graphic that
you're talking about 1912 19. this one
was here's here's the graphic uh explain
this graphic um so this is hand down to
show people right so as you go deeper
and deeper and down right your your
increasing like the pressure of whatever
that object is is exponential this being
the submarine yeah
right so they're saying like okay you
know I don't know how many meters down
but you're saying bike tires go flat you
know pressure at this uh depth would
force water back up a household faucet
okay pressure at this depth would pop
the cork into the champagne bottle okay
not going out going sucked in okay
that's how strong the pressure is here
we are at this depth if you shoot a hole
in a pressurized scuba tank instead of
air rushing out everything because you
the the best way to imagine the you have
all this pressure right
um and it would basically be like if you
watched or crushed a can of soda an
empty can of soda I mean you could be a
full one too but an empty can soda would
be the easiest way is to squish it down
and compress it or like a ball of like
tin foil to show you exactly what would
happen it would implode on itself and
suck everything in I don't know what the
remnants would be but that's at that
point and then you have even further
because this gives you an idea of like
where the ocean floor is
there's a whole section that's like
halfway between where if you shoot it
into a pressure I scuba tank and where
the actual bow and stern of the Titanic
are that's even that's doubled or then a
double but that's another that portion
right there is is down at the bottom so
you have you're in the dark man it's
[__] dark the bottom of the ocean it
is the darkest place in the floor on
Earth okay so the idea that they went
down there
it's a question of like do they know
where they are and if Texas Paul is
correct on his theory the cameras go out
they're [__] nowhere to be seen they
don't have a they don't even have a
viewport it's like the tiniest viewport
also to say oh we're by the we're by
this you wouldn't be able to see [__]
even if you have good lights on the damn
thing exactly so there's a whole and and
that's a lot of it too because like
you're going into an area that you have
a lot of a lot of stuff is being
reflected back to you which is like the
remnants that you're kicking back up
which might be the dirt it could be the
the uh it could be the actual Titanic
itself that are that's falling apart but
that's the whole reason that you can't
have something that is Tethered is
because if you go down and you start
navigating around and going back this
way and doing this especially if there's
someone down there that's not you know
let's say uh quite as trained as they
should be you might get caught and then
you have no other arm right no other
device to come down there and like cut
the tether or pull you back out or like
excavate excavate you from like a
portion of the boat uh and that's the
other problem too is like the fear of
further damage by exploring and who
knows we won't know unless we send
another one down there because they
could be trapped inside right
and the the CBS team was easily trapped
at the in the propeller right in the
very in the very back of the boat and
they were on the outside they weren't
even in the inside of the hole right so
it's stuff like that where it's like
I can only imagine the the terror that
you might be trapped in that situation
go ahead textbook who thinks there's a
guy in the comments keep saying no don't
they have GPS no they don't GPS is you
have satellites geostationary satellites
in a grid all over the planet you
transmit to those satellites The
Satellites transmit back and
mathematically you can calculate where
you are to a certain degree
two and a half miles down on the bottom
of the ocean you're not making that
transmission you're just not it won't
travel through that much water the other
thing is I actually saw a training video
I got a buddy of mine that's a Navy
Chief
um he's talking about the dive training
they do uh with civilians you know deep
sea divers we're not talking about these
kind of depths either we're talking
about you know
a thousand feet things like that they'd
actually showed these divers that were
in training they had you know one of the
pressure pressurization cells that a
camera up against the window and they
took a head they made a uh
um they took bones and cast it inside
um gelatin the the ballistic gelatin to
so you simulate tissue you have you know
the head is not empty there they put
material consistent with the human brain
inside it and then they went and they
lowered the I mean pardon me increased
the pressure inside that chamber to the
depths these divers were working at it
like you know I mean it was on it wasn't
even that deep I mean the human body
can't survive a thousand feet deep but
they just to the pressure that these
divers were working at the human skull
shrank down to the size of a baseball
to the size of a freaking baseball it
crushed all the bone material everything
and just down to the size of a baseball
can you imagine at two and a half miles
deep if there was any kind of cabling
failure or anything like that because
there has to be transmission between the
screens inside the tub and the cameras
outside the mechanics you know all of it
has to be imagine just any loss of
pressure whatsoever it would just be
instantaneous
collapse I mean just I mean have you
seen a a tank car on a tanker where they
just for a railroad tank car where they
forget to open the vent and you get one
atmosphere of pressure it will crush a
tanker car I mean it would just be
instantaneous I don't think they're
going to be there may not be much for
them to find when they get down there
well let me let me tell you something
and I I want to feel sorry for these
people and if they were like
experts and scientists and they did
everything they could do it turns out
well I just read that because they've
now
some of these reports are coming out
about like who was on it and they said
uh 46 minutes ago that's how delayed
into this like oh [__] what should we
start telling people 46 minutes ago we
have just learned that Stockton Rush the
guy that was in there explaining how it
all worked the CEO of Ocean Gate
Expeditions is a board uh as like a a
member of the crew talk about taking
your company down to the bottom of the
ocean God damn okay so I want to feel
sorry right and 250 000 seems like a
bargain
um to be a part of this story but this
is like Bungie jumping off a bridge
without someone there knowing how to tie
the [__] bungee cord to you right
like you're like yeah we're gonna jump
off this bridge I got a bungee cord I
don't know how to tie it but I'll tie it
onto you you tie it on a mean we'll jump
off at the same time it'll be fantastic
this is really what it seems like this
seems like a really a dumb situation
with dummies that have a lot of money it
does because uh
David Pogue I don't know if that was the
guy that was on there as a CBS News
correspondent who was doing the tour but
he said last year he uh the submersible
he said last year the submersible got
lost on the sea floor for a few hours
when he was on in Ocean Gate Expedition
visit last uh last summer he goes I'm
Expedition last summer they did indeed
get lost for about five hours
um and I think it's part of a part of
that but this is one of those things
where it's like uh you know paid to do
this well come on guys you can't feel
sorry you just I don't know
you know I like in the Navy the one
thing that they beat into your head if
you're gonna be on a boat I'm not
talking behind a desk not in a Jag or
whatever if you're going to be on a damn
boat that's the thing that they beat
into you is the sea wants to kill you it
does it wants to kill you and you have
to act as though everything that could
possibly go wrong will go wrong
all at the same time and that's how they
train that's how they equip they do they
train for [__] Munitions to cook off
get hit by a torpedo the boat is sinking
there's Raging Fire there's fire
suppression systems fail everything they
train for that because that's what
happens on the freaking ocean and this
little freaking company I'm sorry man if
you're a freaking there there's no
training for billionaires there is no
training for billionaire you just give a
dumbass that much money and this is what
you get because
there were no redundant systems there
was no rescue weight they didn't have 46
bucks for the controller man off Amazon
they couldn't even build their own
goddamn controller they're and you
bought into it yeah right and also for
people for people who are curious about
kind of what the range that they're
exploring right now
from what I've read it looks like
they're surveying an area that's the
size of Connecticut
so that's how much area they're trying
and so and I want to go back to
something else here I want to go about
something and there are other there I
just want to mind you there are other
countries that are um that are helping
out like not just the U.S Navy yeah yeah
France has sent uh has sent people in
and which what the hell they gonna do
again there's no vessel that exists it's
just basically these [__] I
mean basically what they're trying to do
is they're you know just trying to see
if they can locate them yeah I mean like
it I mean because remember like sonar
can only work so well right and so
they're basically trying to build a
safety net that would Encompass a a like
I mean how far how far does a U.S Navy
submarine like a big ass submarine yeah
that's what I was about to tell you is
is uh the max operational depth of a U.S
attack submarine is our latest and
greatest attack submarines is 450 meters
like like a built by the United States
Government research for [__] 100
years I mean that's the best of the best
right
yeah it's got a crushed depth of like
600 meters or something like that it's
like 600 to 900 miles
crash
able to function yeah 450 meters is Max
right well here's here's here's what it
reminds me of
um it reminds me of the movie well a
couple different movies
um and I think this is what happens
because you say billionaires need
training and I think sometimes they
watch these movies and they believe
their own [__] like uh the the movie
don't look up you remember then uh where
the scientist is like yeah no problem
there's uh no problem don't don't be
alarmed don't be alarmed only you know
who that was based though too right Elon
Musk yeah um you know the other the
other movie that comes to mind is the
the Glass Onion
um where it destroys the Mona Lisa
because another another person that was
based on Elon Musk gets gets out in
front of his own ego and here we have a
bunch of billionaires and I I you know I
know the audience thinks this is sad and
all that but this is what they wanted to
do they spent their money to do this
they knew the risk the guy from the news
report read the [__] disclosure out
to you out loud
like you're gonna die okay there was no
regulation there were no safety
standards because it doesn't exist for
them well and the reason why is because
Nancy you go ahead Nancy Rose put a
comment out there that says no one
deserves to die like that
if I could choose a way to die
this would be it this would absolutely
be it
you mean freaking Hyperbaric put me in a
hyperbaric chamber
drop me to the maximum amount of a
pressure pressure that I can survive and
then pop the seal because it is instant
freaking genius man you do not have I
don't even know there to realize you
won't even hear the pop in your ear
before every bit of liquid in your body
rushes out of you I mean it you know I
mean it's just
that is the way to die we have video
evidence
someone in the comments you know you
won't even hear the pop
somebody someone or someone I didn't
want to address something someone in the
comments said there are safety standards
uh not now this these there are no
craft and I will I will read you
something I was just reading a moment
ago uh
it says uh sorry sorry again and I'd
hate to bring up the the example of the
bungee jumping but this is exactly what
that would be is it'd be like two really
rich guys standing on the edge of a
really high bridge and they're like well
we've got bungee cords and we're rich
and we're really smart and we watched a
YouTube video on how to tie a bungee
cord I'm not really a professional
neither are you let's go ahead and try
this without any advice any anyone else
giving us
um so four four hours ago and you could
even find this in a blog post from 2019
before hours ago was reported that the
missing submissible Titan was not
classed so this is addressing the
comment that I saw that it was this was
uh regulated by safety protocols uh the
missing submissible Titan was not
classed by an independent group that
sets safety standards as most charted
vessels are they even set in a blog post
in 2019 that Titan wasn't class because
the technology was so new and there
Innovation Falls outside of the existing
industry Paradigm it said there are a
multi-year approval cycle due to a lack
of pre-existing standards again this is
so in other words so in other words
these rich people are really [__]
impatient right here
yes and there are patients is costing
them their lives yeah exactly and
specifically classing usually checks if
vessels meet standards in buoyancy
number of Life rafts Hull materials
making sure that it has a safety value
associated with it to say like this is
safe for human use right this is safe to
go under these depths it was not
sufficient to ensure safety so I just
want to address that one comment that
said it was it literally was not classed
at all for safety that's probably why
they went in it was complete it was all
on you just like we played in the video
you sign away a waiver that says no one
is liable or or uh or responsible except
you the person who pays the money to go
into it
Leroy says here on uh on YouTube Mars
hey I'm I'm all for sending these
[__] to Mars let's get them all
on one big old cockroach it and send
them to Mars let's do it let's do it you
know though you know I got to tell you I
have huge amounts of respect for James
Cameron in regards to this what what
Gabe was just talking about
you know he did when he went down
to the bottom of the ocean
folks he spent a fortune not only did he
have his Engineers design a craft that
would make it down there but he had
other Engineers double check their work
he had certifying boards take a look at
it I mean he I mean he really went to a
lot of trouble just to shoot a video
that this company did not do I mean they
just did not and and folks you're 400
miles off the coast of Newfoundland
all right yes it's a shipping Lane yes
there are ships if you're going down
there are no ships near you that can go
to that depth that has a submersible
that can go to that kind of depth it is
massively it's one of the deepest places
in the world I mean it is you know it's
not like the Challenger Deep out in the
Pacific but it is still two and a half
miles down and that takes a lot of very
specialized equipment and folks we've
got people spending millions of dollars
jumping through their ass to get
equipment to these people to find
[__] corpses because I guarantee you
there's no way to do it in time I want
to give you a fact I want to give you a
fact and I know this
um did you know from the highest point
of Earth the very highest peak of Earth
to the very lowest depth of the ocean is
about 11 miles okay think about that for
a second it's 11 miles from the highest
point on land right the top
the highest point to the lowest depth in
the ocean it's 11 miles and these
[__] are two and a half miles
down just to give you perspective of how
far down how how Under the Sea they are
under the sea
Under the Sea I'm I'm just saying and I
know you you think I'm [__] gross but
hey these people are gross it's gross
that you would spend your money to go do
this to die in a [__] coffin that
makes it look like a submarine where
you're controlling it with a forty
dollar controller from Amazon you're a
bunch of dumb impatient [__] because
you got too much money and you don't
know what to do with it so this is what
you do with it you you look is this the
way you want to die fine whatever
whatever you want to do I'm not against
people dying this way that's what you
want to do assisted suicide fine by me
hop in the submarine [__] wait that
sumbitch down at the bottom of the ocean
let's see how you make it fine whatever
you want to do especially you want to
pay 250 000 whatever that's fine but
don't act like don't act like these
people are smart intelligent
decisions here I would even go far as to
jump on what uh what Texas Paul said is
the idea that James Cameron right right
not only not only for Titanic right in
in the regulations but also in the
development of new technology that could
be used for the exploration of the
Titanic right like even if you look at
Avatar the guy wanted to make that movie
for years and developed three brand new
3D cameras to actually tell that story
uh if you've ever seen the sets but
basically and now they're using it in
all kinds exactly and so he the the guy
Jesus Cameron he's a [__] by the way
did you know that I didn't know there's
a dick
but I will say I know that's why he's so
adamant about sticking in there and I'm
gonna I but I will I will give him
credit and that credit is due and like
he had a vision right and he was like I
want to go explore this thing and no one
can do it but I need to get down there
for the for the film but also he has his
own passion and interest and he ex like
they made again they made a Disney one
that was uh that was more of an
exploration around it but again on
Avatar he was like well the technology
doesn't exist yet so I want to invent a
3D camera system for production and then
eventually he was able to do it and now
he's pushed the limits of what we can do
in cinema which I will say like Gotta
Give him props for that but it's it is
one of those things where you know at
least on that team
he was like oh [__] like we have to be
careful we have to be safe we have to
have regulations we have to make sure
that we can actually do these things so
we don't risk other people's lives and
then this Ocean Gate was like well if
you pay me enough money I'll send you
down there and it's like that's that's
not always the the best
path forward right like I don't know
who's funding I don't know who's who's
backing this but like the idea that
they're like all right just pop you in
turn the you know turn the the lock and
then we shoot you down there and then
it's like yes control with control with
the Xbox or the the windows controller
which probably doesn't even can't I
don't even know if we can really buy
that thing like on Amazon Prime you can
buy it but I don't know if it's like
one of those things that you can get in
two days kind of situation but well we
we ran way over time there's one more
thing I want to show here yeah yeah and
before we go if the submersible Titan
story has you thinking uh just wait for
it trip to Mars trip to Mars anybody
um here is uh Elon Musk he's gonna give
you a trip to Mars 100 billion dollars
and I'll I'll I'll spot you a little bit
of money if you wanna turns out
regulations
are good oh hmm that's that's kind of
funny it's kind of funny and it's kind
of funny hey uh Texas Paul I want you to
give a Shameless plug here I know you
got a show going tomorrow you got shows
on Sundays everyone go to
realtexaspaul.com but give us your plug
for tomorrow
yeah it's Sundays and Wednesdays at
today 10 10 a.m join me it's going to be
a good show tomorrow we're going to talk
about all the some of the things that uh
uh Joe Biden's gotten done as far as
manufacturing is concerned we're going
to dig into a little bit more of what's
been going on with Eileen Cannon uh it
should be a good show folks
Gabe you got what was that coming up
soon yeah I gotta what was that uh I
gotta what was that on uh Rhonda santis
saying that he'd be OG OG Posse members
with Jesus and uh I'll probably do one
on this uh interview that Donald Trump
did where he basically just admitted to
everything that he was guilty of
well of course you will of course you
will and what you should do is subscribe
to the Tony Michaels podcast you don't
want to miss a single episode Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific right here on YouTube Twitter
and twitch so follow us on Twitter at
Tony Michaels pod also on Twitch at
twitch.tv slash the Tony Michaels don't
forget to renew your Prime subscription
if you want to get the controller
um that that they had on this submarine
it's only 49 or 39.49 if you use your
Prime account you can go to Amazon buy
one of those momento but what you should
do if you got a prime accountant you
just link it to your Twitch account go
to thetonymichaels.com there's
directions like the fourth link down
just take the Amazon gaming one free
subscription you get you can use that
controller probably
um in that situation and you can give us
your one free subscription on Twitch
this link to two accounts also you can
watch us on Facebook live every single
day at the Tony Michaels so if you still
have a Facebook account go over there
and do that until tomorrow
same time same place same laptop Surf's
Up [__] you've been listening
to the Tony Michaels podcast in your
face commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] them [__]
them
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn hadass Beacon